ạ Alo alo alo h nhá Tôi thử
Tôi vừa nhìn thấy nó lên quả đỏ luôn ạ
Chắc là to lắm rồi th cỡ rồi đợ tí chỉnh
cái bên này cho nó tôi ẩn nó đi cho để
tôi luôn hiển thị nó ra
[âm nhạc]
Alo
Ờ đại khái thì tôi bảo là hôm trước tôi
sẽ cố tâm sự hết bởi vì có nhiều cái tôi
như tôi đã nói thì tôi định hướng cái
kênh của mình vẫn
là kiểu chia sẻ góc nhìn quan điểm cũng
như là rất nhiều cái trong cuộc sống của
tôi ở dưới góc độ của một wibu một voer
một dân IT nói chung
Ừ nên là tôi sẽ chia sẻ tâm sự khá là
nhiều chứ không hẳn hướng đến là kiểu
chỉ dạy học đươn nhiên là những cái gì
mà tôi cảm thấy hay ho bao gồm cả việc
học tập chia sẻ rất là mẹo vặt rất nhiều
thứ thì tôi vẫn sẽ muốn chia sẻ m không
hiểu gì tôi không ạ nghĩa là tôi sẽ tôi
còn định hướng chia sẻ nhiều cái nữa
không phải mỗi kênh này kênh học
tập kênh học tập thì như tôi đã nói là
trên mạng hay là tất cả mọi người đều
kiểu có quá nhiều ấy thì tôi không nghĩ
rằng là kênh mình gọi nhở xịn đến thế
Tôi chưa từng đành ra C mình kênh mình
xịn đến thế kênh mình đúng kiểu khác
biệt giữa các kênh khác ở điểm
là mình là chính mình đấy mình khác với
người khác đúng không ạ Đấy thì mình
phải chia sẻ những góc nhìn kiểu kiểu
như thế nghĩa là có người sẽ không có
người sẽ có thể suy nghĩ giống mình ở
một vài điểm đấy thì mình thì gần như là
một cái nơi kết nối C thứ thôi tự nhiên
tôi thấy n n xống kiểu Chắc là nếu mà để
mà để mà nói là kênh không muốn nổi lắm
chỉ gọi là chia sẻ cùng chung góc nhìn
thì tôi thấy tôi bắt đầ thấy na ná giống
tều Phạm à Ừ anh ấy cũng kiểu dạng là
cũng không muốn mình thành người nổi
tiếng cũng kiểu dạng là cũng không Không
hẳn là kiểu dạng là Khuyển
dùng từ Nhau
Thì đại khái ông ấy anh đấy chỉ cần tập
trung vào những cái người mà có cùng
Trung góp nhìn hay mọi thứ thôi chứ
không cần là quan tâm việc quan tâm đến
là phải cố Chiều theo số đông tôi cũng
không hẳn là tôi muốn Chiều theo số đông
tôi
chỉ Nếu mà muốn chiều số đồng chắc là
tôi sẽ kiểu trở thành con người khác
hoàn toàn
rồi A có một vài
người hỏi kìa Để thử trả lời nha Em đi
inter 5 tháng làm Angola 3 giờ thử việc
bắt học view làm dự án mới N Anh chúc
mừng em
ờ cứ học và làm thôi nó cũng đều ja
scrip hay nói chung là ngôn ngữ
thì nếu mà có thể thì công ty mà áp dụng
ng ngôn ngữ mới hay là công nghệ mới thì
càng ngon mình C mình học đấy cái đấy
thì mình càng thuận tiện em không học
đại học mà học g la ở trung tâm Hiện tại
thì em đang học mô hình mvc theo spring
boot Theo anh thì có nên vừa học vừa đi
tập hai học xong rồi đi nhỉ Anh khuyên
là học xong rồi đi nếu mà em có thừa
thời gian thì em nên làm dự án pet
Project hay gì đó để nâng thêm trình chứ
bây giờ thực thực tế là mình ra ngoài đi
đi thực tập thì kiểu gì ở đấy cũng là
ngồi học thôi chứ cũng không được trực
tiếp làm cái gì cả
và nhiều nơi nó cạnh tranh lắm nên thành
ra là kiểu anh nghĩ là không
trường hợp quan lệ nn thì query nào cho
nhanh anh
à n n á Ý ông là Tôi thường gọi nm hơn
kiểu nn ngay giống kiểu hai cái thằng
bằng cấp nhau
là tôi thấy là thực ra là nó cái quan hệ
nn query nào cho nhanh chuẩn là với SQL
thì Joy là đã tối ưu nhất rồi trừ khi là
câu của ông Joy ông không đánh Index
chuẩn Xong rồi ông que điều kiện Mọi thứ
không hợp lý Nói chung là để trả lời mấy
cái câu về SQL này đúng là các bạn phải
có trường hợp nó cụ thể để mà đánh giá
chứ nhưng mà còn lý thuyết lý thuyết
chung ấy thì là join là tối ưu nhất rồi
hạn chế subc mọi
thứ còn hồi trước là tôi từng làm tôi
lúc đấy Lúc đấy mới kiểu mới
à gọi như là mới đã đã từng làm là dùng
Joi tối y c ch cho hết cỡ rồi không được
Xong rồi anh ở công ty đề xất là em cứ
tách ra là hai câu select riêng ý thậm
chí đôi khi nó nhanh hơn thì tôi tách
hẳn ra nghĩa tôi lấy ví dụ là giả sử tôi
có bảng order và order order kiểu
product nghĩa là bảng order và chi tiết
order ấy thì tôi lấy ra toàn bộ order ID
xong tôi à qu in trong cái danh sách
order ID đấy thì thậm chí thế còn nhanh
hơn nên là khó mà kiểu đấy đánh giá được
chính xác lắm nói chung các bạn đúng
kiểu là phải làm nhiều các bạn mới có
thêm kinh nghiệm chứ lý thuyết là không
đủ Anh ơi em muốn hỏi xíu là hiện tại em
đang phân vân giữa dep web
và aws hình như là Amazon đúng không
Amazon service mà đúng
Thi web thì vẫn có thể làm cái kia thôi
mà nhở Tôi thấy có sự gì khác biệt đâu
nhỉ dep web mình hướng ha dep ố thì cũng
kiểu biết về mấy cái kiểu các thứ kia mà
quan trọng là ông ông học riêng cái de
web ông đã hộp bơ rồi ấ nên là cứ tập
trung vào một cái đã lên dần dần đ bốp
xong câu hỏi làm gì khi thất bại trong
lĩnh vực mình từng theo
đuổi
quá
ờ có một sự thật đó là ừ m ông biết cái
từ Never Give Up nó dịch dịch kiểu nó
viết tắt là gì rồi đúng không
ạ
g
up đúng không ạ m không biết mà Never
Give Up
là là không không không bao giờ bỏ cuộc
đúng không ạ nhưng mà nó vết nhưng mà
vết tắt nó sẽ là ngu Nghĩa là tôi tôi
hôm nay tôi vừa nói sinh viên về vụ này
xong
thì
mình ngã ở đâu gấp đôi đấy Cuối Cùng
Mình chứng minh được mọi người là mình
làm được thì nó hay nhưng mà Nếu giả sử
mà mình không làm được thì nó viết tắt
của từ ngu đúng không ạ nghĩa là chỉ là
cổ chấp các
thứ thì tôi có đùa với sinh viên Đó
là
ờ có đùa về sinh viên Đó là kiểu cứ cứ
never gip up đi biết đâu về sau còn ngu
hơn thì sao nĩ chỉ
ờ ấm chỉ kiểu có rất nhiều lúc khó có
thể khuyên được các bạn là cứ cắm đầu
theo theo đuổi một cái gì đó đến cùng
bởi vì chúng ta cuộc sống nói chung ấy
thì tôi nghĩ là tất cả nó đều liên quan
đến cái giới hạn thôi mình phải tự đánh
giá được cái giới hạn của mình đến đâu
Nếu giả sử là kiểu mình biết được mình
làm
thử đến một cái ngưỡng nào đó mình cảm
thấy là đấy gần như hết sức rồi thì một
là ông cảm thấy Ông vẫn muốn BP phá lên
được ok Còn không thì ông cảm thấy là
cái số thời gian Ông bỏ ra này quá nhiều
và về sau ông nghĩ là còn nhiều hơn nữa
điển hình điển hình trong ngành công
nghệ tin này giả sử Giả sử ông cảm thấy
ông không không phù hợp ông việc ông học
có thể thời gian đầu thì ông có thể chậm
hơn người khác thì cái đấy trình độ năng
lực tùy từ người nhá Nhưng
mà ông học kiểu dạng là bị bò xa các bạn
quá rồi Kiểu thế nản rất nhiều yếu tố
nữa
thì cũng phải cân nhắc thật bởi vì ngành
công nghệ công ty này tính ra nó vẫn là
ngành kiểu nó thay đổi mọi thứ khá là
thứ thứ thì kiểu thứ nhất là bạn cùng
lứa đi làm hết rồi thứ hai là kiểu công
nghệ đấy nó cũng dần dần báo Hòa rồi thì
tỷ lệ chọi Mọi thứ rất là cao nên nên là
nói chung là Mọi thứ ông phải đánh giá
ví dụ bây giờ tôi gần đây tôi có đánh
giá
là ông muốn thử cái gì ông cứ thử nó
trong vòng tầm 3 tháng ít nhất là như
thế để ông đánh giá xem ông phù hợp với
nó hay không rồi chúng ta nói chuyện
tiếp chứ chúng ta không thể chưa thử đã
bỏ cuộc thì nó lại nó lại là một con
người không có chí Nhưng mà nếu mà có
trí mà là mà cứ cứ cố đến cùng kể cả cho
dù thất bại rồi vẫn cố gắng thì đấy hành
trí bảo thủ à không phải trí Tiến thủ
Đâu Chí í bào thủ đấy Nói chung là
ờ cái này các bạn biết được cái giới hạn
của bản thân càng sớm càng tốt biết được
tính cách của mình các th thứ ví dụ tính
cách của mình Ok là một người mình là
một người hay bỏ cuộc Ok cố gắng khắc
phục là mình không dễ bỏ cuộc và ngược
lại nếu mà cảm thấy là mình cũng kiểu cố
chấp
quá thì mình cũng phải học cách kiểu đôi
khi buông là một cái tốt đấy Nói chung
là cái này phải linh hoạt Linh độc tôi
khó mà khuyên được các bạn là là kiểu
dạng là cứ cắm đầu đi xô phía sau mấy
hôm quay trách tôi Tôi không thể khuyên
các mấy ông bỏ cuộc kiểu bỏ học đi hay
là mọi thứ được mấy ông sẽ lại qua lại
trách tôi nói chung là đầu tiên phải
trách bản thân chính mình đã bởi vì
chính mình còn không hiểu mình thì làm
sao mà những người khác khuyên mình được
đúng không ạ tất cả mọi người khác
khuyên nó luôn luôn chỉ là lời khuyên
còn việc hành động mọi thứ đó là niềm
tin vào bản thân ông đúng không
ở đây này là là kiểu kiếm yêu đi này
nhưng mà nhưng mà khi mà kiểu em đấy cứ
cố chấp à theo đổi một mối tình gì gì đó
thì mình cũng phải cân
nhắc tôi không Tôi vẫn chưa khuyên em
đấy là từ bỏ đâu nhưng mà chị là kiểu
mình sẽ phải thay đổi rất nhiều cái nếu
mà mình vẫn muốn theo đuổi Còn không thì
còn không thì nó sẽ mãi vẫn
à
inform Tích không ạ Mình
nữ trước đó đã học và thực tập dự án ở
công
bài toán ở đây đó là cái việc lưỡng lự
của các bạn
nó nó như nào Nếu giả sử là bây giờ Bây
giờ là kiểu như này tôi bảo các bạn hạn
chế để về sau mình sẽ ân hận vì mình
đã làm gì đó hoặc là chưa làm gì đó
Nhưng mà thường là mình sẽ ân hận vì
mình chưa làm hơn bây giờ giả sử là kiểu
ông à Bạn không không theo đấy đúng
không
ạ thì về sao bạn có ân hận khi mà không
theo không Nếu bạn cảm thấy bạn tự tin
nói là về sau em sẽ không ân hận đâu thì
ok Còn nếu về sau bạn sẽ ân hận vì bạn
đã không theo đuổi cái đam mê hay mọi
thứ của
bạn thì tôt nhất là bây giờ bạn biết
phải làm gì rồi đúng không ạ đấy nó chỉ
đơn giản thế
án java luôn em phải vào làm ngày đêm
tìm
hiểu thì nên học Java spring trước hai
spring trước anh anh không biết một
trong hai cái đấy luôn Không biết khuyên
nhau nhưng mà đại khái thì em cảm thấy
là muốn học cái gì thì ừ đấy có bạn kia
là học co trước cho Hiệp vản chất đúng n
học co trước hiệp vản chất
rồi anh mai ngày mai anh đi dậy anh gần
đây Anh vừa phải mua con này xong con
này con thp bây giờ chuẩn bị đi dậy
để nói chung bất đắc dị Thôi mai anh đi
Dậy thì vậ anh phải làm quen dần con mar
à con Windows quay lại Windows và bây
giờ anh sẽ để con m ở công ty làm việc
thôi vì bạn bản chất là máy công ty Giao
thì giao cho mình để mà phục vụ công
việc thì anh sẽ không dùng cho mục đích
cá nhân đấy thì anh sẽ dùng con máy
này đây là ting bass carbon X1 Zen 11
thì
end tôi nhớ rõ ràng là tôi nhớ cái từ Bá
đấy nó trong
cái lời bài hát nào đó khiến cho tôi bị
ám ảnh cái từ đấy x Ai bảo tôi là back
back end mới đúng back en Nếu dễ kiếm
việc ở Việt Nam chắc js Java
Python dễ kiếm việc khi bạn làm được
thôi còn không thì cái nào chẳng khó như
nhau đúng
gia tài làm app học tiếng Anh bị CP
chê Thực ra thì cái việc là tỉ lệ của
việc setup thành công và setup thất bại
nó cũng kiểu nó cũng khá là khác biệt
kiểu Nó là một cái gì đó kiểu tỉ lệ nó
cũng ngang bằng không không thể nó ngang
bằng đánh lô đánh đề được nhưng nó là
như
sẽ quen những người xung quanh là là sẽ
có nhiều stup thất bại các thứ các thứ
còn nếu mà xung quanh các bạn toàn
startup thành công thì có khi không đến
lượt bạn đâu bạn sẽ là thằng thất bại
trọng tiếp theo
đấy Nói Thầy có bị cho là vùi dập ước mơ
không nh Nhưng mà đại khái
thì một khi s up thì các bạn xác định
phải tư tưởng đó là các bạn không nên
nghe lời người khác nói Các bạn nên tìm
những người có cùng trong chú hướng và
cùng làm
Nếu mà giả sử các bạn đã có tầm nhìn đủ
mọi thứ và bạn tin vào mọi thứ Bạn cần à
Bạn làm là đúng và xã hội cần điều đấy
còn nếu mà bạn nghĩ rằng
là kiểu dạng là lượng người cần nó chỉ
cần ít hay Vân Vân Vân nó bị phụ thuộc
rất nhiều yếu tố ấy đấy thì bạn phải xem
xét lại tôi thì bản thân tôi không phải
dân kinh doanh cũng chưa phải con người
thành công gì cả Tôi không dám pháp phát
biểu liều khuyên cái gì tôi Tôi chỉ nói
là tôi cũng từng Hồi trước từng định làm
Ừ mục tiêu là 29 tuổi sẽ mở quán cà phê
xôi bây giờ m ch 29 tuổi cưới vợ tôi còn
đang nghĩ có khi tôi phải chọn M trong
hai h không hòa không Cả hai không biết
được hai năm nữa chưa biết được
11 blot là gì không biết anh Anh bảo rồi
anh muốn thử mọi cái thứ mới nhất của nó
nếu mà lỗi thì lỗi mình nếu mà có gặp
những vấn đề gì Mình lại sửa mình quay
lại Win để xác định nó như thế mà còn
dùng cái gì nó mà kiểu Tất nhiên là vẫn
Thiên vẫn bởi vì đi Đi dậy và nói chung
phục vụ đi làm thì nói chung là vẫn nên
ổn định một tí nhưng
mà nghĩa là phải ổn định không biế nỗi
lắm lỗ vặt như anh không nghĩ là có
nhiều cái bị thế đâu Nói chung là quay
lại Vịnh Win ngày hôm nay tôi công nhận
cũng mất khá nhiều thời gian ngồi cài
lại môi trường mọi thứ và thấy là đúng
là giùng má thì nó ít nhất là nó kiểu
Đúng là dành cho người lười khá tiện đỡ
phải kiểu cài đặp mọi thứ cũng rất là
nhanh dễ chạy Comment nhiều Ừ chắc là
dùng Linux chắc cũng
tân được xếp Trong một cuộc thương thảo
đúng sự thật như thế Tôi khuyên à tôi
xin chia sẻ ở đây ở đây chắc ít người
nghe Chắc là ít người biết thôi chắc
không sao thì hôm trước tôi có từng nói
mấy ông không nhỉ đó tôi từng đề xuất
sếp tăng lương xong rồi cuối cùng thì
ngày hôm sau thì tôi bị bất đắc dĩ kiểu
bị gài qua đây dậy thì tôi thì thật ra
sếp vẫn có vẻ đang xem xét cái phần
duyệt tăng lương đấy nhưng
mà nhưng mà hôm trước tôi có nói chuyện
với sếp là là em à các sếp tạo điều kiện
cho em kiểu
à bây giờ nghỉ một ngày trong tuần hàng
tuần để đi dậy em sẽ làm bù vào thời
gian khác em bù lại không cần phải tăng
lương C không cần dượ cái đ sẽ tăng
lương kia nữa thì sếp có vẻ đồng ý rồi
nhưng mà sếp vẫn kiểu Yêu cầu là chỉ làm
thế được trong khoảng thời gian và nói
chung là đà bảo tiến độ các thứ các thứ
cũng như như tránh làm ảnh hưởng đến a
à ảnh ảnh hưởng đến môi trường làm việc
các thứ bởi vì tính ra thì công ty tôi
rất tạo điều kiện thoải mái các thứ
nhưng mà mình không nên Thứ nhất là mình
không nên lợi dụng nó vì tính ra mình
vẫn là đi làm công ty nghĩa là nó vẫn là
bài toán là kiểu dạng là tinh thần tinh
thần lẫn nhau ấy tinh thần vang phòng
các thứ thứ
à mình mình không thể kiểu cứ tự ý thích
làm gì thì làm được Vì chắc chắn nó sẽ
ảnh hưởng lẫn nhau Nói chung là
tôi tôi có vẻ thu xếp được rồi
thôi còn một đống thứ tôi vừa nốt lại có
một đống thứ chuẩn bị để ngày mai làm th
này kiểu bây giờ phải ngồi soạn soạn
giáo án Tuy là giáo án có rồi nhưng mà
tôi cảm thấy
là hơ đây An đây hơi
cũ Ừ nhưng mà nó sẽ bị nhược điểm đó là
nếu bây giờ tôi soạn giào án thì cái
người sau dạy không biết người ta có dạy
được theo phong cách của tôi không đ tôi
chỉ dạy lớp này chỉ cho mỗi P và m qu
xong ng xong rồi Kiểu không chưa đến
larel luôn người sau dạy dạy sang larel
mà khác cái format của tôi thì sợ sinh
viên thc ra hồi trước tôi từ căn nhắc
cái vụ này đó là kiểu
được dậy thấy nó tính á hơi dở hơi dở
chừng một tí với sinh viên nhưng mà rất
khó để mà có thể ôm được
mình không thể làm được tất cả mọi thứ
chư vẫn
phải vẫn phải sẽ cần có người hỗ trợ sau
các thứ và mình không thể đi theo sinh
viên mãi
được
mua nhà mua đất mua xe không nếu mà ông
hỏi câu này chắc chỉ có mua nhà mua đất
mua xe xe giấy ở hàng mã
Thôi em chuẩn bị đi xin thực tập mà ít
người Tuyền lel quá thì sao ạ Thực ra
tuyển anh thấy vẫn rất nhiều chẳng qua
là về cái trình kiểu fer thì công nhận
là cạnh tranh nhiều nên là Ừ mình phải
tự nâng trình lên Đương nhiên mình vẫn
là fer thôi nhưng mà CV mình phải xịn
hơn những người khác bảo rồi mấy ông còn
đang tự cảnh tranh lẫn nhau ở trong
chính đây cơ
mà cuối năm nay shop lấy vợ mà shop quên
à Đâu tôi nói thế đâu Tôi bảo là tôi
luôn bảo Cuối năm tôi nói cụ thể năm nào
đâu trước em có chích hack
game Như chc kịp làm thì game đá vậy
chưa Ok không hi vọng ông không chơi mấy
cái à Chắc ông không chơi mấy game tôi
chơi đâu Vừa đi làm công ty back end vừa
vay để mở quán cà phê thì ổn không
nhỉ một khi mà em vẫn còn đang đi làm
thuê ấ
và không có vốn có sẵn ấy thì đừng có
nên vay để mở một cái gì đó cả theo tôi
như thế vì khi muốn mở sát một cái gì đó
rất nhiều lúi do đương nhiên em vẫn vẫn
có thể V
rất nhiều người vay vẫn thành công nhưng
mà nó kiểu dạng là mình cứ phải tính đến
bài toán rủi ro đã mình đừng nghĩ bài
toán tích cực the cả m
ạ tôi m à Tôi sẽ dạy ở Bách Khoa Aptech
ở ngày mai sẽ nhưng mà sẽ dạy ở bên
trong khuôn viên trường đại học vách
khoa Ôi nghe oai nhá xị quá
còn không ném vào máy áo không a cứ ngồi
C hết mọi thứ có thể th ạ chắc ổn định
mà không sao
uptech Xem video của nó thấy giảng viên
toàn lôi chatti ra gõ Cậu hỏi cho nó vào
trả lời học viên tôi sẽ thế mà Ủa
Alo cái việc
mà đương nhiên là tôi vẫn sẽ trả lời
sinh viên mọi thứ giống như ngay chính
bây giờ nhưng B đó nó là có rất nhiều
câu ấy có rất nhiều câu nói chung là nó
do cách thể hiện mình thôi không phải
nói là kiểu Ok Bây giờ giáo viên đ đấy
dạy giáo viên không được sử dụng ai nó
bị nghe bị buôn cười tôi thự thực ra
không quan tâm việc đấy vì chúng ta
không nên kỳ thị ai gì cả chúng ta nên
coi Nó là một cái gì công cụ hay các thứ
đương nhiên là không phải nói là một
giáo viên kể cả không có ai nhá kiểu bây
giờ giả sử thời mà chưa có ai đi Tôi
biết rất nhiều giáo viên kiểu vô tâm thì
kiểu là lôi giáo án ra xong rồi chỉ nói
vẹt hay mọi thứ thì cái bài toán đấy là
muốn thủa rồi cái bài toán ở đây việc
giáo viên này cóu tâm hay không Ví dụ có
rất nhiều câu rất dễ của sinh viên thì
đúng là mình nên gợi ý sinh viên là là
hỏi tra cứu tài liệu giống như hồi trước
tôi cũng thường hay bảo sinh viên tra
Google trước khi hỏi mọi thứ không phải
là trước khi hỏi tôi mà phải quen với
việc là mình ở Dân công nghệ mình phải
luôn tìm hiểu mọi thứ đã chước khi mình
hỏi chứ không Không thì mình thế Nếu giả
sử không có người hỏi thì mình lúc đấy
bị phụ thuộc mình bị ỉ lại quá đúng
không ạ Đấy mình nên tr tài liệu ha Mọi
thứ trước đã đấy cũng như là trên đấy sẽ
trả lời một cách chi tiết hơn đôi khi là
thậm chí chi tiết Và thậm chí còn đúng
hơn so với người dạy luôn bởi vì người
dạy người ta cũng có thể công công nghệ
đấy nó không lỗi thời rồi vân vân nên
tính ra là bây giờ ai nó vẫn là một cái
công cụ khá đặc lực lợi thế nên là tôi
hướng dẫn Nếu mà tôi có hướng dẫn mai
tôi cũng định hướng dẫn sinh viên dùng
chity Mọi thứ vẫ là covos bình thường
thôi đương nhiên là tôi sẽ không à Tôi
sẽ bắt sinh viên không được phép cài cái
gì cả để cho sinh viên thời gian đầu là
phải code cho quen cách code đã chứ gợi
ý code rồi mọi thứ thứ Thế thì nó bị
không hiểu và không nhớ đúng không ạ à
nhưng mà vẫn phải gợi ý nó cách từ khóa
cách tro Google để khi không có mình nó
vẫn phải làm được
đấy chứ nếu mà để sinh viên phụ thuộc
hết vào vào giáo viên thì nó không ổn
đúng không
sau 1
năm trưng à xong
một
làm song một năm trước em có học ja
scrip và làm quen dự án mô hình K doanh
nghiệp bây giờ m quay update TH là phân
lên việc định hướng du học em bây giờ
thực ra các bạn cứ vạch ra cái
du học x rồi Ưu nhược khi mà học tại đây
X rồi Ưu nhược kiểu mọi thứ như nào
Ờ nó nó phải rạch dòn mọi thứ ra chứ bây
giờ đương nhiên là các bạn đang mông
lung nên các bạn phải ghi lại ra giấy
hoặc ghi đâu đấy đểu Các bạn nhìn so
sánh và hỏi thậm chí là những cái người
mà các bạn đỗi khi là các bạn hỏi ví dụ
một người vover trên mạng này thì ra khó
mà đánh giá được vì tôi không hiểu rõ
bạn đúng không ạ hỏi chính người thân
của
bạn những cái người mà cũng hiểu qua
tính cách và họ phải công tâm nhé phải à
phải kiểu dạng là có kiểu dạng là có thể
đưa được những lời khuyên rất là khách
quan ấy chứ không phải là vì vì kiểu
biết tính Bạn nên cố nói lựa lời nào đâu
đấy Nên nói chung là kiếm được những cái
con người mà mình có thể hoàn toàn là về
sau mình có thể nhờ Đưa lời khuyên các
thứ thứ đúng không ạ Đấy thì khuyên mình
bởi vì là đấy là trong trường hợp mà
chính bạn còn đang chưa hiểu bạn cần gì
còn nếu mà bạn hi hiểu được mình cần gì
thì cứ liệt kê hết ra mọi thứ xong rồi
các bạn xong rồi bạn tự đánh giá
thôi không không cần nhất thiết phải là
người nhà đâu Bạn bè ho các anh chị tiền
bối đi trước còn nếu mà Giả sử bạn không
có cái kiểu có những cái mối quan hệ mà
kiểu khó Đưa lời kiểu dạng là để xin lời
khuyên thì khó nhỉ Tôi thường ng kiểu
gợi ý các bạn là đi cà phê Tôi Tôi định
hướng nhưng là nếu bạn ở Hà Nội thì có
thể đi còn không thì
Khó Nói chung là tôi cũng chính bản thân
tôi thì tôi cũng thường hay xin lời
khuyên từ mọi người thôi kể cả nhỏ tuổi
hơn hay như nào đấy không quan trọng đâu
nhá Thì bởi vì mỗi người có nhiều góp
nhìn mình sẽ đưa đưa mình
sẽ kiểu nhận những cái lời khuyên đấy
xong rồi mình sẽ tự đánh giá xem điều
chỉnh nó xem mình có thấy phù hợp hay
không các thứ bởi
vì bởi vì đấy tôi
bảo tôi bảo rồi bài toán ở đây nó vẫn
quay đi quay lại thì đó là người ta
khuyên bạn thì người ta vẫn chỉ là nói
mồm chính mình mới hiểu được là mình
thực sự cần gì mình thấy cái gì phù hợp
đúng không ạ Nó n nà giống như kiểu bố
mẹ đặt đâu con ng đấy à Kiểu bố mẹ mà
kiểu khuyên mình kiểu thằng kia đẹp trai
sáng dạ sáng sủa lắm các thứ thứ cưới đi
các thứ thứ nhưng mà mình cảm thấy không
phù hợp thì đấy là chính mình ngay từ
ngay từ lúc mà mình cảm thấy là phù hợp
Vy không ấy thì nó là cái cái suy nghĩ
mình tự đánh giá được một phần nào đó
rồi cái tình cảm mình đánh giá phần nào
đó
rồi người kia mà cứ cố nói nữa thì người
ta cố thao túng bạn thôi rồi về sau bạn
sẽ tự nhận ra là mình cần như nào đúng
không ạ lịch cà phê à Ừ tuần này tôi xem
tôi rảnh hôm nào nhỉ Tối mai tôi sẽ dạy
trong nhóm sinh viên này
Ừ
hiện tại Thực ra là tôi đang trống vào
tối thứ sáu đấy thích thì mấy bạn anh em
mình làm bổ cà phê nên số lượng cũng
chắc là tầm ba bốn bạn thôi chứ nhiều
bạn cùng một lúc quá thì th cứ trợ mất
chẳng nói được cái gì cả
Ờ có gì mấy ông cứ chủ động inbox tôi
qua Facebook nhá Facebook hoặc Facebook
đi nếu mà rủ đi cà phê cò discord thì
tôi thấy là để công việc mọi thứ khác
gbt thì sao nhỉ Tôi bảo rồi bản chất là
trước khi mà có ai thì thc ra chúng ta
vẫn dùng Google các thứ thôi Đương nhiên
Đương nhiên là bây giờ ai nó còn hỗ trợ
tận răng hơn về việc code các thứ nhưng
mà bây giờ gọi như cái đấy Thực ra nó
phụ thuộc vào chính các bạn nhân viên à
các bạn sinh viên thôi bây giờ thứ nhất
nhá không thể cấm được nó bởi vì rõ ràng
nó là một lợi thế đúng không ạ Nếu mà
việc
là không cho nó dùng các thứ thứ để để
cho nó kiểu không bị không bị ỉ lại ý
đúng không ạ thì rõ ràng nó có thể học
chậm hơn và thôi Thiệt hơn so những cái
bạn mà biết tận dụng nó đúng không ạ à
còn à Tôi cảm thấy nó vẫn là liên quan
đến ý thức chứ Rõ ràng là có rất nhiều
người học nhờ học được tốt s kết hợp với
nó kiểu nó nó còn kiểu nhanh hơn nữa tôi
cảm thấy là bây
giờ mọi thứ đang càng hỗ trợ cho các bạn
tận răng để mà các bạn học Mọi thứ rất
là
nhanh dễ dàng hơn nhưng mà đương nhiên
là các bạn cũng cạnh tranh khốc liệt
hơn tỉ lệ chọi cao hơn mà đúng không nên
là ông nào mà càng bị chỉ cần ỷ lại một
tí thôi cái A tư duy mà tư duy mà kiểu
bị ỷ lại xong rồi không không tư duy
được bài toán các thứ thứ ấ thì ông ấy
sẽ thua thuyệt hơn so bạn đống lứa thôi
Cái đấy là trách bản thân mình thôi chứ
chẳng đừng có trách công nghệ gì cả đừng
có bảo là Ui bây giờ kiểu công nghệ xịn
quá khiến em Kiểu ngu đi À không v toàn
vẫn là mình đúng không ạ Nó n nà giống
như kiểu bây giờ ông ông sinh ra máy cầy
rồi nhưng ông bảo là sợ làm thế Làm gọi
nh sợ làm thế ảnh hưởng đến đến sức khỏe
bởi vì hội trước quen cầy cuốc bằng bằng
chân tay lao động chân tay rồi thì nó
tốt là sức khỏe Bây giờ tự nhiên có thêm
máy cầy các thứ thứ thì tôi chẳng biết
là so sánh thế có đúng không Tôi sẽ cố
nghĩ được cái cách so sánh khác nó nó có
vẻ nó tương xứng hơn nhưng là nhưng là ý
tôi là công nghệ thì nó luôn có chúng ta
không thể
kiểu kiểu cố cố không sử dụng nó để cho
sợ các thứ thứ được nó vẫn nằm ở chính
cái cái ý thức Ừ đúng rồi Cái ý thức của
mình
nv
nvdia chưa
anh hình như là ông này ấ kiểu chê về ai
đúng không nhờ có một ông ở đó chê về ai
Hình như ông đấy à Chắc là tôi tôi chưa
nghe và tôi Tôi không có thời gian để Ui
Nãy giờ còn chưa tâm sự một cái gì nãy
giờ chư ngồi trả lời các thứ thứ kia hết
sứ thời gian luôn đỉnh
dạy on cho những bạn không được học ở
BCH hoa không ạ Ơ thì tôi có đăng mấy
cái playlist các thứ thứ này để dạy on
đây nhưng mà Đúng là tôi không còn thể
có thể thời gian để mà đăng cái play
playlist kiểu hoặc là làm lại th làm lại
cái playlist xịn hơn mấy cái kiến thức
hồi trước
Junior thôi chứ thực ra thực tế bài toán
là riêng ngành IT này đã có rất nhiều vị
trí kiểu rất nhiều nghề Và thậm chí là
kiểu Dạ cà càng chuẩn bị thêm rất nhiều
nghề mới
vì nó kiểu nó cái bài toán nghiệp vụ nó
quá phức tạp các thứ đến chính con người
mình làm Mình còn chưa thạo làm sao mà
thể ai mình có thể tính toán các thứ thế
được ai bản chất là họ vẫn à Theo tôi
quan điểm thì chất ai nó vẫn là học học
từ chính con người đương nhiên là nó nó
có thể phát triển tư duy để
mà tính toán trường hợp khả năng
xảy ra trong tương lai nhưng mà bạn
nhưng mà ý tôi là
nó con người mà nghĩ được thì mình nghĩ
được trước mắt là như thế còn không biết
tương lai là như nào không biết 10 năm
20 năm nữa thì nó sẽ nghĩ ra những cái
thứ mà chính mình còn không TH có thể
nghĩ được thì không biết được
Ờ nhưng là lúc đấy thì tôi nghĩ là lúc
đấy chúng ta sẽ ngồi nói chuyện kiểu khi
khác không Còn bây giờ thì chúng ta nói
thời điểm hiện tại đã Chúng ta không nên
kiểu nói chuyện Quá Xa xôi làm gì cả
ngày mai mấy còn chưa biết mấy ông sẽ ăn
gì Như nào các thứ thử mếu ngồi nghĩ
việc tận chục năm
ơ tôi bảo rồi tôi nhiều video tôi dạy
tôi vẫn kiểu mở Hàn Charity cho các bạn
xem để mà tra câu hỏi để mà trả lời cho
các bạn đấy quan trọng ở đây nó là dạy
các bạn tư duy việc tra Google và và tra
kiểu dùng ai áp dụng ai thôi nó cũng
không phải vấn đề gì cả đương nhiên là
thầy nên nói thêm những cái khác mà ai
đang còn thiếu hay là kiểu dạng là a
không đúng để sửa lại CH đúng giống như
là tôi cũng chia sẻ với các bạn luôn rồi
đó là nói chung là hoặc là kiểu kể cả
cho dù ai đang rất là đầy đủ ý mình cũng
phải chỉ ra mọi thứ chứ không nó tôi bảo
rồi Giả sử không có ai giả sử Thậm chí
không có Google luôn Thời trước đấy là
kiểu có rất nhiều Tôi biết có một vài
thầy kiểu cứ mở slide lên cho đọc kiểu
học sinh hỏi gì lại mở slide lên cho đọc
kiểu các thứ thứ chứ không dạy một cái
gì đó cả không có chia sẻ thêm những góc
nhìn cá nhân hay K K thức cá nhân vào
đấy Thì đấy là nói chung là nó quay đi
quay lại không phải là lỗi của ai hay là
không phải lỗi Google ở đây không phải
lỗi của tài liệu đúng không ạ Nó lỗi ở
chính của cái việc là thứ nhất là thái
độ của người thầy cái sự kiểu có tâm hay
mọi thứ không đấy Và thậm chí là đôi khi
là có thể là do cách kiểu cách tiếp nhận
của mình nữ cách tiếp nhận mình mình cảm
thấy là nó không hay và Người Thầy cảm
thấy là người thầy làm cho mình cảm thấy
là kiểu dạng là
mình người thầy không xứng đáng đấy các
thứ thứ nó rất nhiều yếu tố ấy nên nên
là khó để nói nói
Thế được đúng không ạ Nếu không có cái
này thực cạ cũng có cái kia thôi Người
Thầy vô tâm thì người ta mãi là vô tâm
đúng không ạ hoặc là Nếu giả sử người TH
không vô tâm mình vô tâm đ mình không
hợp với người thầy như thế thì kiểu gì
mình chẳng có cái cớ để nói người ta
đúng không
mỗi năm cái SQL web cơ bản chuyên sâu
môi giới học học viện bán hàng đúng rồi
Đúng rồi em nói thế rất là chuẩn rồi
đúng thứ tự rồi Nhưng mà thực ra là thực
ra nó sẽ chỉ có thứ tự là SQL web cơ bản
chuyên sâu còn toàn bộ những cái Sa sau
đó kia thì đó là những dự án bên ngoài
nghĩa em hoàn toàn thể học xong cái trên
sâu là thực ra là đủ rồi còn mấy cái dự
án bên ngoài kia thì
em nghe cái nào trước cái nào sau cũng
được nó không Không sao cả tuy nhiên cái
càng gần cuối thì anh sẽ càng dạy đúng
là nó nâng cao hơn trước bởi vì chính
trình độ anh cũng nâng lên và anh cũng
kiểu cảm thấy là các bạn cũng đến tầm
giai đoạn này cũng phải biết rồi nên là
nó sẽ nâng cao hơn một tí trước
Nhưng mà thực tế là các bạn học trên sâu
xong các bạn cũng phải gọi nhờ C bập bõm
đi làm rồi Lúc mà những cái video Tôi
đang Chia sẻ ngay bây giờ Đó là chia xe
dành cho các bạn đã đi làm rồi Gần như
là các bạn Thời gian đầu ấy mà bây giờ
còn xem được những video này thì nó có
lợi bổ sung cho công việc các bạn chứ
tôi không thể hướng đến là luôn là dạy
theo kesser được Bởi tôi đã từng thấy có
rất nhiều kênh như thế luôn họ nói đi
nói lại rất nhiều cái toàn bộ những kiến
thức mà fer đề biết à cần phải biết
Nhưng mà thực ra Junior là họ đã hiển
nhiên biết rồi và nói đi nói lại luôn ý
kiểu ví dụ ví dụ điển hình kiểu tháng 1
Này ông sẽ nói về một cái tính một vài
cái kiểu TP hay mẹo này Các th thứ đấy
thì tầm tháng tư tháng năm thì ông lại
nhắc lại cái đấy phát nữa rồi đến tháng
11 tháng 12 lại nhá l ph nữa tôi cảm
thấy phất cáu vãi xong rồi tôi cuối cùng
tôi hủy theo dõi mấy cái kênh kiểu như
thế
nĩa thôi Tưởng nó sẽ chia sẻ thêm rất
nhiều cái mà về sau mình sẽ cần không nó
sẽ chỉ nói đi nói lại những cái frer cần
biết thôi đấy Nên là vì tôi đã từng áp
cảm kiểu kênh kiểu như thế nên là tôi
cũng sẽ không đươ nhên tôi sẽ không đi
vào con V xe đồ đy nhưng Bộ lại là các
bạn nếu mà cần những cái kênh kiểu như
thế thì có có rất nhiều kênh như thế
luôn mớ không hiểu gì tôi không
ạ nhưng mà đương nhiên là sẽ luôn có
người mới nghĩa là quan trọng là nó n ná
là mình muốn đánh vào tệp khách hàng nào
ấy Tôi muốn đương nhiên là tệp khách
hàng cũ của mình cài cầm vơi đi mình nên
kiểu luôn hướng đến người mới thì tốt
hơn đúng không ạ người mới luôn có mà
đúng không người cũ sẽ cả cả dụng dần vở
người cũ cũng bận rộn rất nhiều thứ
nhưng mà tôi thì tôi thì tập trung thực
ra tôi không hẳn là tập trung vào người
cũ đâu Tôi tập trung nên là tôi có hướng
đến hoàn toàn kênh này dạy học đâu nếu
mà kênh này dạy học và xác định Tôi luôn
luôn phải dạy lại những kiến thức cũ
luôn luôn dạy lại những kiến thức kiểu
fesser các thứ các thứ
ờ nên là nó kiểu tôi tôi đi dạy ở trên
trường đã phải ngồi nói đi nói lại những
cái đấy thôi thôi bây giờ qua kênh này
tôi nói đi nói lại cái đấy nữa cho tôi
chết mất đấy tôi lại còn không phải con
người thích nhắc đi nhắc lại một thứ nữa
nên thành ra là tôi sẽ nói nên là kênh
này bản chất là nó không phải để dễ học
học mà code để chia sẻ rất nhiều cái có
thể là những cái đấy Có thể tôi từng nói
từng nói rồi Như tôi sẽ kiểu tâm sự chia
sẻ lại theo góc nhìn khác
đấy thế thôi được không
nhất khi đang học ngành nào tôi Thực ra
tôi cảm thấy là tôi phù hợp với cứu ình
của những cái bạn mà học tránh ngành
hơn câm tư sự đổi Hồng hái Chính Đúng
tôi muốn ghim cái cái bình luận kia quá
như mỗi tội tôi lỡ ghim cái bình luận
này
nữa Bây giờ chúng ta cứ coi như là đấy
chúng ta đã qua năm nhất năm HA bây giờ
đi thực tập rồi đấy kênh Tôi đang phục
vụ là dành cho đi làm Junio rồi này
chẳng hạn đang hướng đến xio này đấy thì
V Cứ cho là sẽ tầm năm bao nhiêu
nhở 22 23 à
Ừ tí tôi sẽ để cái tiêu đề ở trên kênh
đúng kênh này phù phù hợp cho 22+ kểu
thế không phải 18 cng
nữa tuổi hồng gì R này
chẳng mấy ông ngồi nghe này kiểu tầm tôi
tôi hồ không nghe được mấy cái này Ui
mấy cái mấy cái này tôi ghi cũ lâu lắm
rồi ấ
những điều bạn nên biết sớm hơn ok Cái
này tôi lưu lại cho mấy ông nhưng mà Mấy
ông chắc là mấy ông xem rồi hoặ chưa xem
kệ Xóa bớt đi không thời gian để ngồi
xem lại đâu ạ thậ tiệc xin lỗi yeah link
chết cũng được Xóa bớt đi hôm n sẽ ngồi
ngày dọn tâm
sự tôi sẽ cố dọn hết tâm sự hết cái đống
này không Tôi bảo có rất nhiều cái tôi
cố ghi lại Tôi còn lỡ ghi kiểu ghi kiểu
nó kiểu tiêu đề ấ mui y chính ấy x cuối
cùng Nhiều lúc tôi còn không cố phải nhớ
xem nó là cái gì
chừ tính cái tiếng này thôi chấp nhận
tắt tiếng
mấy ông là kiểu theo đuổi đam mê hay cái
gì gì đó nhưng mà đương nhiên là nó hơi
bị xáo rỗng khi mà mấy ông bảo là cảnh
Toán cơ má tiền là rất nhiều thứ nhưng
mà thực tế thì để mà lý tưởng để mà Lý
Tưởng ra thì chọn một công
việc bây giờ tôi Tôi từng nói rồi thì
phải đó là kiểu các bạn một ngày có 24
giờ đúng không ạ Cả đời Các bạn thì một
ngày vẫn chỉ có 24 giờ thôi đương nhiên
nó sẽ lệch thêm vài giây thì không nói
nhá n cứ bỏ qua bội đi cứ cho làm tròn
24 gi nhá Đấy thì nếu mà chuẩn ra thì
1/3 cuộc đời Các bạn để ngủ Mỗ một ngày
ngủ 8 tiếng đếu như là có bạn ngủ nhiều
hơn có bạn ngủ ít hơn tầm đấy đấy tiếp
theo thì 8 tiếng còn lại có thể là à 8
tiếng nữa thì có thể đi làm đúng không ạ
thường bây giờ làm giờ hàh chính tầm 8
tiếng và 8 tiếng nữa là dành cho kiểu
những cái việc khác bao gồm là không
phải đi làm thì mấy ông có thể ở nhà với
vợ con hay gì gì đó đấy thì rõ ràng là
rõ ràng đây Nó là kiểu 8 tiếng ngủ thì
đương nhiên là mấy ông cũng nên đối xử
rất là trân trọng nó nhá nghĩa là chỉ là
nên có cái đệm êm này nên gối các thứ
thứ mọi thứ phù hợp thoải mái cho mình
thoải mái giấc ngủ đó là thoải mái phần
1/3 cuộc đời của ông rồi thì làm cho cái
Tâm trạng mọi thứ cuộc cuộc đời cuộc
sống ông sẽ kiểu cơ thể nội tạng của ông
sẽ được cải thiện đi đấy tiếp đó là tiếp
theo là tám tiếng làm việc kia nếu mà
ông làm một công việc mà ông luôn ghét
ấy dùng từ ghét nhá chứ không phải không
thích đâu mà ghét là nói thì thì ông gần
như ông ghét 1/3 cuộc đời của ông luôn
rồi ông hiểu V tôi không ạ Nên tốt nhất
là Nếu có thể thì
thì nên làm công việc nào đó nếu mà đam
mê được thì quá tốt với mà đam mê được
mà kiếm được tiền Chứng tỏ là có lợi cho
xã hội nữa thì càng quá tốt Còn không
thì ông sẽ phải sẽ phải làm sao đó có
thể p ham công việc đấy để pass tham cái
đam mê của ông hay gì đì đó nhưng mà nói
chung là tôi nghĩ là nghe thế mới cũng
phải biết cân nhắc là sao cho mà kể cả
Bây giờ có thể đang làm cái thứ không
thích để để mình có thời gian để học để
làm những thứ mình thích vân vân Nói
chung là cũng phải thay đổi dần chứ
không về sau ông sẽ khó chịu Ông cảm
thấy là sẽ rất nhiều lúc kể không muốn
đi làm Muốn bỏ cuộc C thừ thử nhiều chứ
tỷ lệ đầy cao mà ông nghĩ xung quanh ông
thậm chí chính ông Bây giờ ông đang bị
rơi tình trạng đấy có nhiều người như
thế mà đấy còn 1 PH3 còn lại là dành cho
không phải cho công việc chắc là cho gia
đình hay các thứ thứ thì cũng phải nên
xây dựng gia đình hoặc là các mối quan
hệ xung quanh n cũng nên ổn tí để cho
mình thoải mái sống trong đấy đúng không
ạ
À đấy là mặt lý thuyết nhá Tôi chưa làm
được đâu nhưng mà nó mặt lý thuyết
ờ
vấn thì giơ hết lý thuyết
phỏng vấn mình mỗi người trả lời
lý thuyết một phần thôi các bạn cũng
không nên kiểu quá lo sợ điều đấy Ờ các
bạn nên cứ xin người xin cứ nên chủ động
phỏng vấn là bản chất nó là cuộc đàm
phán hai chiều các bạn đừng để bị biến
nó thành một chiều đâ kiểu người ta hỏi
mình trả lời mình sẽ hỏi lại họ rất
nhiều thứ bao việc họ bao việc bao gồm
việc hỏi lại về công ty hay thậm chí là
đứ nhên khi họ hỏi mấy cái câu hỏi để
hỏi phải xem xem cái trình độ hay mọi
thứ chuyên môn mình đến đâu thì mình
không nên nè tránh mình nên thừa nhận là
mình giỏi yếu khoản nào cũng gọi là như
nào cho người ta xấu cho người ta thấy
tầm 80 ph các bạn 20 ph thì Né đi được
thì có thể né và đều hướng họ đến cái 80
ph cái có lợi kia của bạn đấy trong
trường hợp ông có lợi 80 ph nhá Còn nếu
mà ông 80 ph ông có hại tôi nhất là đúng
rồi cũng không phù hợp với công ty thật
Ờ nói chung là
cuộc phỏng vấn không bao giờ biến mình
thành một nơi mà kiểu đợi đợi bị
xử đợi để mình được thoát các thứ thứ
đợi để mình né hãy biến nó là một cu một
cuộc kiểu gần như là chính họ cũng cảm
thấy kiểu khó thở khi mà ngồi nói chuyện
với các bạn theo kiểu là u nó nó nó mấy
cái kiểu chí quá k các thứ mình mình
cũng cần phải mình phải cần né các thứ
thử
nói ở đây không phải là chỉ là các bạn
đi đe dọa người ta đâu nhé Nói chung là
tôi nhưng mà Mấy ông hiểu với tôi mà
đúng không
anh Ok hết rồi thì ra trường Thực tập có
ổn không
nhỉ Anh nghĩ là Em làm xong người đấy
thì em vẫn phải làm thêm những cái
project th thứ trong những cái khóa đấy
của anh thì cũng hướng dẫn các bạn làm
thêm hai một hai cái đồ án một cái đồ án
Cơ bản một cái đ án nng Cao ấy thì em
làm xong cái đấy em hoàn thể đưa tập hồi
đấy có cam kết mà đó là cam kết kiểu
không phải cam kết kiể chắc chắn đầu
nhưng mà cam kết
là là kiểu các bạn HC xong các bạn chắc
chắn sẽ hiể rất
nhiều để các bạn sẽ phải gì tiếp theo
các bạn định hưởng các bạn sẽ bớt Mung
lung hơn
nhiều đấy mấy ông có thấy có ông nào
quay lại đây tuy là tôi để kênh công
khai nhá Mấy ông có thấy có ông sinh
viên nào quay lại ở đây chửi tôi không ạ
Ít nhất là ch thế tôi cảm thấy la quan
như thế cũng chưa có Sinh viên quay lại
chừ mình sinh viên chỉ quay lại cảm ơn
Thôi đương nhiên là tôi không thu tiền
các bạn nói thẳng các bạn cũng chẳng có
thể cáu có thể khó chịu tôi cái điểm nào
đó chắc thế thì cũng chắc là Thối kệ
Nhưng mà ý là tôi cảm thấy tôi vẫn LC
quan là tuy dậy nhiều nhưng mà Chưa
bị chưa bị nói là dạy không có tâm bao
giờ mình vẫn hết sức
vì vì cái lý tưởng của mình thôi Đấy là
mình muốn dạy làm mọi thứ tốt nhất có
thể còn đương nhiên là là hết khả năng
của tôi mà vẫn thể không đáp ứng được
nhiều người thì thì chịu thôi
đúng không
cái cái tinh thần các bạn sẽ bị bất ổn
đã cái đấy Đều chắc chắn nên là không
không nên ngủ
ít còn về những cái bệnh các thứ thứ
khác thì nh C rất nhiều đúng ạ Bảo hiểm
Ừ tôi định nói về bảo hiểm thế tôi cũng
gần đây tôi từng là một người kiểu khá
là ác cảm với nó nhưng mà Gần đây tôi
thay đổi rất nhiều quan điểm và tôi có
đi mua bảo hiểm rồi tôi có mua bảo hiểm
nhân thọ tô sẽ không quảng cáo bất kỳ
nơi nào ở đây cả các bạn hỏi thì chắc
là g nhà đương nhiên là tôi vẫn sẽ chia
sẻ thẳng thắn khi các bạn hỏi cái gì đó
nhưng mà tôi sẽ không quảng cáo một cái
gì cả thì tôi tôi sẽ chỉ gọi là khoe đi
ch khoe đi khoe những cái gì mà tôi cảm
thấy rất xứng đáng rất là tốt và đã trải
nghiệm Nói chung là cũng đủ thì tôi mới
khoe còn những cái mà tôi không chưa
chia sẻ không chia sẻ thì có thể đơn
giản nó chưa đủ thế thôi
cho người khác
hiểu thì tức là mình chưa hiểu code Nhì
cái này nhiều ý tố chứ em Thứ nhất là kỹ
năng mềm em em vốn em nói chuyện người
khác có dễ hiểu hay không hay chính
người khác khó hiểu
đúng không thứ hai về chính tả nữa tôi
cảm thấy chính tả của bạn cũng cần phải
sửa lại nữa nên cải thiện chính tả em
nhá
chính tả đâu Mà cú pháp mọi thứ nó sai
có ông nào gợi ý bạn ấy sai những cái
lỗi gì phát Tôi hơi lười bắt bẻ Ở đây Ờ
đấy nhưng mà tại sao tự nhiên tôi phải
nhắc điều
đấy Không không phải cố ý gì đó Kiêu
kiểu dạng là đặ kích công kích hay gì cả
mà không nói là tôi có quan điểm đó là
khi mà các bạn Cẩn thận tính các bạn Cẩn
thận ấ bao gồm việc làm tài liệu hay mọi
thứ làm tài liệu đương nhiên là phải gõ
word gõ các thứ thứ và đương nhiên phải
đúng chính tả đúng cứ pháp Mọi thứ ổn
rồi
thì khi bạn cẩn thận cả những cái đấy
thì code các bạn sẽ rất là cẩn thận còn
khi mà các bạn kiểu kiểu viết Mọi thứ
rất ẩu kiểu như này thì các bạn code sẽ
rất là ổng lộn thuộng thứ là nhìn qua
nhìn qua tất cả các bình luận ở đây của
tất cả các bạn các bạn thể đánh giá ngay
luôn ông nào đang rất là cẩn thận ông
nào đang ờ gọi nhỉ nó nó thể hiện đương
nhiên là cách nói chuyện của mình thể
hiện một phần tính cách của mình mà đúng
không ạ Đấy thì mấy ông sẽ tự đánh giá
được
mà nên là tôi tôi tôi bảo tôi không công
kích cá nhân gì kiểu bảo là bạn như này
bạn tệ hay các thứ thứ mà tôi nói là
mình cải thiện mình gọi là tôi cứ nói
bản thân là mình kỹ tình đi không phải
khó tính đâu kỹ tính kiểu để để ý chi
tiết từng cái một để mà làm nó chuẩn chỉ
thì những cái khác mình sẽ chuẩn chỉ
đúng không ạ
th ông kia nghe thế xong ông ấy viết
viết chính tà Mọi thứ ổn vừa nãy gõ
không
dấu thực tập khó không anh Anh 53 muốn
thực tập sợ không ai nhận sợ không ai
nhận thì chính bản thân em cũng đang tự
ti về về mình rồi thì đương nhiên là em
còn sợ em thì đương nhiên là ai ai dám
nhận em nữa đúng không ạ
ờ nên cải thiện bản thân đế em cảm thấy
Thứ nhất là em phải Thắng chính mình đ
em tự tin là em làm được đã đấy thì em
mới đi phỏng vấn em thuyết phục người
khác là tao làm được thì người ta mới
tuyển các bạn Còn nếu mà chính mình còn
cảm thấy mình còn không làm được thì làm
sao mình có thể phỏng vấn kiểu lúc phỏng
vấn thì người phỏng vấn lại phải đi
thuyết phục ngược lại là em làm được à
đúng không ạ Mấy ông thc Thường mấy ông
vẫn bị tôi thấy là đa số ở đây rất nhiều
người bị tôi bảo tôi hơn nhiều người
không phải hơn về trình độ hay mọi thứ
các bạn tư duy khẳng định có khi các bạn
IQ có nhiề bạn còn cao hơn của tôi có
nhưng mà tôi luôn tôi luôn nghĩ là tôi
thắng được nhiều người ở cái tâm lý tôi
biết được là thứ nhất là mình Trình
độ mình đang ở ngưỡng như nào giới hạn
Mình đang ở đâu và Mình thắng được cái
bài toàn tâm lý của chính bản thân mình
cái thứ thứ nhiều người không thắng được
cái đấy nhiều người run nhiều người ngại
rất nhiều cái yếu tố khiến cho họ thiếu
tự tin và thiếu tự tin không làm được
nhiều thứ lắm đấy thiếu tự tin ông ông
sẽ ngại và va chạm ông ngại tham gia làm
vài cái rồi Đúng là trình độ ông sẽ
không cao bằng người ta Vì ông Ngại làm
đúng không ạ Tôi không ngại làm gì cả
nên thành ra tôi tôi cài càng nâng trình
mình lên
ny Ờ chẳng lẽ tôi khuyên mấy ông vạo c
mấy công ty đa cấp để cho nó rèn về độ
tự
cũng là một cách mà vị chửi vào mặt
kiểu Tôi đã từng có tôi có kiểu có hai
tính cách à tính cách còn lại tôi thường
hay chửi tôi nhiều lắm thường hay xì vả
kiểu mày không làm à mày làm kiểu Mày
làm thế này à Hay là mày mày không làm
thì ai làm đấy Vân Vân Vân rất nhiều cái
mình không tự nghĩ một là mấy ông cần
người khác thúc ông Hai ông tự thúc Ông
đúng không
ạ
không Nghĩa bây giờ trụ được đến 3 tháng
rồi Hay như nào chưa hiểu ý
emm trụ được đến bây giờ tháng thứ ba
rồi đúng
quên được
em bây chuẩn bị biến đ k suy rồi Ờ ok
nhưng đại khái Thì tôi quan điểm về cái
bảo hiểm này thứ ra quan điểm chung về
cái về vấn đề sức khỏe đó là tôi có quan
điểm thế này đó là đương nhiên nhiều
người quan điểm khác tôi hoặc đã từng
người khuyên tôi kiểu khác kiểu là phải
luôn quan tâm sức khỏe chứ mình không
phải là người có điều kiện để mà nếu mà
có vấn đề gì thì mình không Mình làm gì
có tiền mà chữa đấy đã từng người khuyên
tôi như thế nhưng là tôi tô vẫn chỉ giữ
sức khỏe mình cái ngưỡng gọi là chấp
nhận được nói thẳng là mình cũng không
khỏe mạnh lắm cũng lời vận động rất
nhiều thứ nhưng mà còn gần đây Đúng là
tôi quan tâm hơn về sức khỏe nhiều hơn
cho dù rõ ràng là cũng chưa có một cái
dấu hiệu gì cả n Tôi nghĩ là đến cũng
đến lúc rồi đấy và đặc biệt là mình cũng
gọi là dư giả hơn tài chứng một tí thì
mình cũng nên đầu tư mọi thứ khác nữa
chứ không phải chứ Để tiền đấy nói thẳng
cũng chẳng để làm gì cả nên là tôi cũng
bắt đầu đầu tư dần bao gồm cả bảo hiểm
các thứ
bảo tôi mới tìm hiểm Tôi không biết
khuyên mấy ông như thế nào tôi a Tôi nhớ
Tôi ghi cái này vào t để tôi định khuyên
cái gì đó cơ nhưng mà tôi không nhớ được
Bây giờ tôi khuyên gì xin phép
xóa khi nào nhớ ra ra tôi sẽ lợ ghi lại
xong đấy tôi Đôi khi tôi ghi mấy cái
kiểu mỗi mấy cái tiêu đề ấ V xong mình
không nhớ
được tiếp theo thần lin g tị với chúng
ta Đây là một chích một phần thôi của
một câu nói của một á thầ Ở trong thanh
trận chiến thanh choy rất là
không thể tiếp cụ kết nhận tôi muốn thôi
Không có gì
Ờ cái này là một cái rất là hay Phim này
ngoài phim hay mọi thứ ra và tôi thất
tình thất à Khá thích thần thoại kh Lạp
ra thì
câu này ông ông thỉnh tháng đíp đíp ông
đi lấy mấy câu kiểu chị dẫn kiểu này đi
tan gái nữ đây à Nhưng mà đại khái câu
này hay bởi vì nó nói lên cái việc là nó
đúng cũng là là đúng quan điểm sống của
tôi nó chỉ là như nh Cuộc sống quá ngắn
ngủi kiểu quá có rất nhiều cái ngắn ngủi
luôn
ấy ngay ở thời điểm hiện tại có thể c
ông đang cảm thấy ông còn rất là trẻ C
đầy tương lai mọi thứ phía trước mà
không ông biết nghe cuộc sống vô thường
được chưa ông nghe câu đấy chưa không
biết câu đấy thường hay nói khi nào cuộc
sống vô thường ấy thường hay nói khi mà
Đột nhiên có một người nà nó mất một
người nà nó kiểu đột nhiên mất theo kiểu
là kiểu Họ đang rất là khỏe mạnh rất
nhiều cái đấy
Ờ tôi từng nghe Câ Đấy vài lần rồi và
tôi cảm thấy kiểu đấy thì mọi thứ nó
kiểu Tuy gi mấy ông có đang ngồi đấy mấy
ông có thể đang ngồi tính vợ tương lai
mấy ông như nào Tìm kiếm công việc mọi
thứ như nào Mọi TH thứ khác đột nhiên
một cái biến cố gì đó xảy ra đúng không
Đấy khiến cho ông không phải khiến ông
như khiến cho ông hay người thân ông tôi
không muốn nói gở thế ch đang nó là nó
sẽ có rất nhiều thứ xảy ra có thể bật
chợt xảy ra mình không thể lớn trước
được nên là mình tính ra là tuy là mình
vẫn đang phải sống vì tương lai nhưng
mình vẫn phải sống cho hiện tại đã mình
phải tận hưởng cuộc sống ngay thời điểm
hiện tại đã nói thế không phải là mấy
ông bây giờ tắt máy đi chơi đâu
nhá
nghĩa tôi thường ha bảo m mọi Tôi thường
ha bảo cho mọi người xung quanh tôi và
cả sinh viên Tôi là kiểu jolo đúng không
ạ m không biết Yolo rồi hình như tôi từc
nói cái đấy một hai lần gì đó rồi Yolo
ch only li one đúng không
hai cách hiểu một là sống một lần thôi
Xõa đi tận hưởng đi thử thử ăn chơi nhậu
nhẹt đi Cái gì nên thử kể cả đồ chất
kích thích đấy Đấy là người khác nghĩ
một cái ông Long nghiện nào đó khuyên
cái đấy Không phải tôi tôi sẽ khuyên là
là sống một lần nên là nên là mình sẽ
phải cố gắng hết sức mọi thứ đươn nhiên
là bao gồm cả tận hưởng hưởng nhưng mà
không nên làm gì mọi thứ có hại theo kéo
gây ảnh hưởng sau này
và mình nên cống hiến làm mọi thứ hết
mình có thể tôi sống Ít nhất đến thờ
Hiện tại tôi vẫn đang làm được mọi thứ
mình muốn mình muốn thì mình mới làm
nhưng mà khi mình làm đều rất là tốt nên
là chẳng ai Quyên bắt bẻ mình bất cứ cái
gì cả tôii thẳng luôn Sếp tôi có nhiều
lúc cáu tô vãi trưởng kểu mình tính là
mình vẫn là một thằng hơi vô kỷ luật ở
trên công ty khá ngứa mắt không thể làm
gì được sẽ có những người đồ kỵ mình
nhưng mà vẫn không thể làm gì được vì
tính ra là mình vẫn sống tương đối hết
tâm có thể bao gồm việc hết tâm với
người khác và hết tâm với công việc
đấy m ông làm thế thì chẳng ai bắt bẻ và
chẳng ai nói ông và ông cảm thấy là ông
sống như thế sẽ rất là xứng đáng đúng
không ạ hả Tôi không ba giờ nói xấu xếp
nhá Tôi chưa từng nói xấu xếp cái gì nhá
Còn một khi mà tôi đã nói mà Ông cảm
thấy là xấu đấy là nó xấu thì chứng tỏ
xếp tôi xấu thật chứ không phải là
tôi Ơ đấy Thực ra đ cũng chính câu của
sếp bình tôi nói luôn đâu Em có nói xấu
đâu Em nói sự thật chẳng qua là sự thật
là anh xấu
tị với chúng ta là chúng ta chỉ có một
đời sống nên là mọi khoảnh khắc của
chúng ta đều có thể là cuối cùng nên bao
gồm cả xinh đẹp hay mọi thứ tuổi trẻ hay
là mọi thứ Cơ hội nó sẽ hạn hữu đôi khi
nó Chỉ Đến Một Lần Thôi đấy có thể là
theo như tôi thường hay kiểu tôi thường
hay gặp nhiều người cũng hơi mê tín à gì
đó là kiểu tin và tín hiệu vũ trụ tin và
đủ các loại các thứ thứ ấ Nói thẳng luôn
là họ bị thiếu
bị tâm lý họ bị yếu nên họ mới phải cố
dựa vào một cái gì đó tin như thế thì
tôi cũng đi khuyên người ta là kiểu đấy
Bây giờ cứ cho tín hiệu vũ trụ đã dẫn
bạn đến đây để ngồi nghe tôi khuyên là
bạn thức tỉnh đi đấy có thấy bạn đừng có
tin bạn đừng có tin và mấy cái đứa xám
xám trên mạng nữa để mà tự đứng dậy và
sống cuộc sống của chính mình đi các thứ
các
kiếm tiền lúc trẻ cho lúc về gi sao nhỉ
đừng có nghĩ cá quá cáa siêu đến kiếm
tiền cho lúc về già nữa em Anh vừa nói
rồi chắc gì tôi không phải nói gở là
chắc gì không sống đến già nhưng mà
kiểu bây giờ ông tôi bảo rồi không Ông
chỉ tính được căng 5 đến 10 năm nữa thôi
đừng có nghĩ cao siêu quá đừng có nghĩ
bây giờ kể cả ông tiết kiệm Thìn nhiều
phá chư chong 10 năm nữa chắc gì 10 năm
nữa cái số tiền đấy còn giá trị hoặc là
10 năm nữa ông kiếm được nhiều hơn thì
sao đấy Kiểu thế nó bị buồn cười ấ nó
chung là
kiểu có rất nhiều cái không thể tính xa
được như
hay nhà tiên chi nào đó tôi không quan
tâm quan tâm V hiện tại đi á đó là
Ờ ông lo cho 5 năm nữa 10 năm nữa là
căng quá rồi là cái trong phạm vi ông có
thể tính đến rồi nó còn bài toán Khả Thi
được dự báo thời tiết trong ngày hôm nay
nó còn sai đừng nói đến ngày mai không
ngồi nghĩ tận 10 năm
nữa đúng không ạ xô còn kêu là cho về
già ôi về già của ông là bao lâu nữa Mấy
chục năm nữa
không Thế nên là thế n Tôi cảm thấy là
kiểu mình bị Đôi khi mình cứ bị tính gì
đó quá thành tự đấy cứ cho mấy ôm thườ
anh nói câu gần đây là gì á over thí
King à Cái gì gì đó nghĩ nhều quá chẳng
giải quyết được vấn đề gì cả
nghĩ bây giờ giống như sếp tôi nói đó là
à đây tôi có câu ở dưới
này đừng nói vấn đề à cái đoạn này giải
pháp chẳng qua là do là lúc đấy đang đi
trên đường tôi tôi ghi rất nhiều cái này
là lúc mà tôi đang đi trên đường tôi
ngồi nghĩ x tôi ghi lại à over linh tinh
à Cũng đúng nó sẽ thường là linh tinh
thôi nó chẳng nó chẳng giải quyết vấn đề
gì chỉ khiến nó não mình nó bị tốn tốn
việc xử lý rồi xong rồi những cái lúc mà
ông xử lý thế não ông cứ cho là não ông
bị mất mất đi chết xám đi Phả không ngồi
nghĩ mấy cái ta tim mà đừng nghĩ nữa đấy
Đừng nói vấn đề mà cả giải pháp đó là
ông có nghĩ được giải pháp không ông Ông
thấy là ok có vấn đề nào nào đó xảy ra
đúng không Ông có nghĩ được giải pháp nó
không Nếu mà nghĩ được ok nghĩ được hết
mọi giải pháp đi xong rồi Thôi kết thúc
còn nếu mà không Ông nghĩ là ông cảm
thấy ông ngồi nghĩ mãi chẳng ra được cái
giải pháp gì cả thì đừng có nghĩ
nữa Cái gì không làm được giống như sếp
tô bảo cái gì khó quá mình cảm thấy
không giải quyết được Tống người khác
tìm người giải quyết hộ mình chứ mình
đừng có ôm nó ôm nó thế Mình bị kiểu
delay à Bị kiểu dạng bị chậm bị kiểu nó
sẽ là cái hãm mình lại lúc đấy mình
không thể làm được việc khác mà rõ ràng
mình không thể làm được việc này đúng
không ạ Đấy đấy là một trong những cái
rất là tệ đúng không ạ kiểu tự nhiên
Mình bị mình bị kiểu bị chun chân lại
đứng ở một chỗ nhìn trông nó rất là kiểu
đần ấy nó thẳng đần ấy đúng không ạ Rõ
ràng là không giải quyết được thì mình
phải đi tìm cách đi tìm đủ mọi cách khác
chứ không phải mình cứ lao vào vết xe
đấy rồi mình cứ dậm chân tại chỗ ở đấy
đúng không ạ
Đấy và tiếp theo là khi bàn với tất cả
mọi người khác thì không nên nói về mỗi
cái tiêu
cực không nên nói về kiểu các vấn đề tao
tao gần đây tao gặp vấn đề này các thứ
th thử đấy Bây giờ bạn đi Nói chuyện
người một người mà người
người đấy ngày nào phản nàn ngày ngày
nào kêu cà ngày nào nói về cái từ
cực bởi vì rõ ràng là bản thân
họ không nghĩ là được giải pháp đươ
nhiên nhưng mà họ cũng chỉ ôm mỗi cái
đấy rồi ngày nào nhắc đi nhắc lại thế
Bạn cũng cáu đúng không ạ Đấy là một mối
trượng bạn cảm thấy là người đấy t xích
đấy tiêu cực chính xa đấy Thì bây giờ
mình không muốn trở thành người như thế
thì mình như nào mình nói giải pháp mình
nói ra đương nhiên giải pháp đấy có thể
không khả thí lắm như mình cứ nói ra hết
mọi ý tưởng của mình để xem người kia có
gỡ rối được cho mình hay không còn nếu
mà không không có một cái giải pháp nào
để giải quyết nó ấy thì tốt nhất là đừng
có nói sự thật như thế vì vì gọi như là
không thì ông sẽ chỉ một người tiêu cực
mà người khác muốn tránh xa ông thôi đấy
có sự thật là như thế
đúng không ạ mình phải nghĩ là một cái
gì đó trước đã làm các thứ thử mọi thứ
đã còn nếu không thử được thì thôi cố né
hết sức cái vấn đề ra đy nhiên vấn đề nó
mãi còn đó nhưng mà mình cố né được thế
nào thì né mình phải thửng mọi cách để
né Ok không
là kênh tâm sự sự Nữa kênh này kênh gỡ
dối cuộc
sống nghe thật là kiểu gần đây có cái
cái gì Podcast healing
à Giọng tôi chắc là nó cũng kiểu trầm
trầm Mấm Mấm nà chắc healing mà đúng
không Chắc
thấy có động lực phát triển bản thân
không còn buôn thả bản thân đúng đấy ông
lấy ra một cái động lực nào đó như thế
đặc biệt đấy đây Cứ cho là không biết
ông con trai con gái nhưng mà tôi cảm
thấy là thời tôi quen mấy bạn có cho bạn
lớn hơn tuổi bạn ấy Cũng là từng trải
bạn ấy cũng cho mình có thêm động lực
kiểu hai người hiểu hai người cũng kiểu
hiểu hiểu sự đời kiểu không không làm
khó nhau ấy đấy Thông cảm V nhau và có
thể hỗ trợ nhau trong nhiều cái cũng như
là cũng như là kiểu tạng là đấy thì mình
có động lực đượcc các thứ thứ và mình
đấy gần như là nó là một người bạn đồng
hành hơn là một người kiểu lúc nào cũng
kìm mình xuống ấy Người Đồng Hành có thể
thận chế hỗ trợ mình rất nhiều cái thấy
hay mà tôi cảm thấy hay trong đ khi mà
tôi đến tầm tuổi này tôi cảm thấy cũng
bớt hay rồi vì tôi muốn người ta lập gia
đình Còn bây giờ tôi thời điểm này Tôi
chưa lập được gia đình nên tôi cũng hơi
lo người ta nên tôi mới Đành Thôi những
m quan hệ của thế nh Thực ra Tôi thấy
rất là hay mấy ông tôi Tôi không biết là
nên khuyên như này không khuyên là nếu
hãy kiếm máy bay đ khi còn có thể
à không không không nói không không
không nên nói thế nhá không nên nói về
chuyện tình cảm như thế khuyên như thế
hơi tệ
như nhưng mà khuyên ở đây đó là cả cha
cả nữ luôn đó là chúng ta phải luôn kiếm
những mối quan hệ không cần nh thiết và
người yêu là thể giúp đỡ được cho chúng
ta ít nhất là về mặt cảm xúc đã đúng
không ạ sau đó tiếp theo về công việc
hay mọi thứ khác Tránh những cái mối
quan hệ mà kiểu nó không đi đến đâu cả
và mình cũng chả xác định được cái cái
cái kiểu Ờ xác định được nó là đem lại
cái gì cho mình thử
thử tại bâ là mình còn đang rất là bất
ổn thế đúng không ạ Mình không nên làm
người khác bất ổn theo thế
và mơ tưởng hơn thì trắng
tay có thể mua nhà không
anh
Ờ tôi thì tôi đã cố hết sức kiểu kể về
thân phận hay là các thứ kiểu kể về hoàn
cảnh rồi vì tôi không muốn sự thương hại
hay là một cái gì đ đó cả nhưng mà chắc
chắn là tôi là một người đúng nghĩa là
không có gì trong tay may may mà chơi đế
nỗi là kiểu nợ nần các thứ thứ đương
nhiên là đ nhà có rất nhiều người còn
hoàn cảnh hơn tôi như vậy tôi đến thời
điểm hiện tại thứ là tôi vn chưa có nhà
đâu chưa có gì cả nhưng tôi đếm thầy
Hiện tại tôi thấy là ít nhất là tôi đã
sống tương đối gọi là đủ đã đủ đã thứ
hai đó
là tôi gặp được các người sếp hay mọi
thứ kể mọi một quan hệ ổn để mà những
người đấy có thể hứa hẹn được với tôi đó
là lúc đầu tôi không tin đâu nhưng mà
cảm thấy là đúng là nó đ càng ngày càng
đi đúng hướng thế nên tôi bắt đầu tin
dần V việc là
là kiểu về sau có thể nếu mình muốn thì
vẫn có thể tích góp để mua nhà được
trong cái đời này của mình nhưng mà
đương nhiên là cái việc là mình có muốn
hay không và cái việc là mình phải tích
góp các thứ thứ rất nhiều cái thứ nữa
nhưng mà ít nhất là với công việc của
tôi hay mọi thứ tôi thì hiện tại tôi cầm
thấy tôi đi hướng nên là tôi cứ cứ chia
sẻ thật thôi là với tôi thì tôi có thể
làm được Tôi không biết các bạn thế
chào đấy tôi cũng chẳng biết th kiểu đên
nhên ha Hello bạn à
Ờ mới đọc báo xong si s đừng h lờ trình
hãy chuyển sang học kiến thức khác hữu
dụng hơn Ôi ngồi nghe mấy ông đấy nói
làm gì mấy ông ấy đôi khi là kiểu định
hướng dư luận để mà tăng giá cổ phần hay
cổ phiếu gì gì đó Vân Vân thứ nghe tham
khảo cho vui
thế mọi lời nói của họ ra đều có ý cả
và chắc gì ý tốt Tôi đang khuyên mấy ông
ở nãy giờ có thể nó hoàn toàn là ý tốt
với từ thật thật tâm của tôi Còn mấy
người kia chưa chắc là thật tâm của họ
đâu đôi khi là đậm chí còn bị báo nhét
chữ và mồm nữa đấy là thật tâm của cái
thằng viết báo rồi chứ không phải thật
tâm của cái người nói nữa đúng không Nói
chung nghe mọi thứ phải trong một cái
hoàn cảnh nào đó thì bạn mới hiểu rõ
được cái câu nói đấy chứ Bạn nghe bạn
trích dẫn mấy cái câu nói kiểu như thế
nó chết
đúng nghĩa HM chỉ mình cũng phải đặt một
cái gì đó cao lên một tí rồi mình sẽ cù
phấn đấu đúng không
không Anh chẳng biết chia sẻ Ý em là sao
chia sẻ có mấy cái nguồn kiểu để mà tham
khảo hay là gợi ý em cái gì về nguồn thì
thực ra là chỉ có trên g Hub chứ thực ra
chẳng lưu một cái gì cả anh cũng không
có cái đấy để anh chia sẻ và thực ra anh
Nếu anh có anh không có thể ngại chia sẻ
vì gọi nhỉ Sợ nhiều ông kiểu lấy về thì
mấy ông làm luôn đ án các thứ các thứ ấ
không nên nói chung là anh nghĩ là em cứ
đấy chắc lại đệp khúc rồi hỏi chat VT
gợi ý xem là mình cần một cái đồ án đấy
thì nên có những cái gì và đếnn cái tầm
ngưỡng nào của phù hợp cho Juno fer cái
gì gì đó bởi vì em đang đi học mà đúng
không đấy để em ngồi em làm em kiểu nó
sẽ phân tích qua một vài bài toán nghiệp
vụ để mà em kiểu bắt tay vào xem làm
được không Thế cũng được Chắc là hỏi ch
GT được
đấy xem là áp dụng thôi xem hỏi xem nó
trả lời được không nhá
À tôi đang
là sinh viên năm cuối đại học
Tôi muốn
làm dự án về social
Media pp Thực ra là anh còn thấy cái
social Media của em kiểu nó quá rộng
luôn ấy nên thua hẹp lại đấy nghĩa là
ngay trong câu hỏi của em em đã không
tìm hiểu quá kỹ để mà hỏi một câu nó đầy
đủ hoặc em đang hỏi câu quá mở thành ra
là kiểu thành ra là kiểu câu trả lời của
em sẽ chỉ tương đối mở chứ không thể chi
tiết được các bạn đôi khi phải hỏi một
câu gì đó rất là chi tiết đương nhiên là
đôi khi các bạn sẽ nghĩ rằng là Ui hỏi
Thấy dài quá Người khác sợ người ta sẽ
kiểu Thấy dài quá ấy các thứ thứ như Nói
chung là mình phải biết
cách ngắn quá không ổn dài quá thì cũng
dễ gây người khác choáng sợ thật Nói
chung là phải đến cái ngưỡng ở đó đúng
không ạ à đương nhiên bình luận ở đây nó
cũng giới hạn nữa nên là nói chung là
cũng khó vì tính ra mấy ông hỏi qua
livestream như này thì các bạn hỏi cho
gọi là như này một cách kiểu tình cờ các
bạn thấy các bạn hỏi thôi chứ nếu mà các
bạn hỏi chuẩn th các bạn sẽ phải hỏi qua
rất nhiều cách
với trình độ
chity này đang nhập đăng ký đấy cập nhật
h xong rồi bạn thể hỏi chi tiết hơn là
kiểu cái này thì áp dụng công nghệ gì
các thứ cái này áp dụng công nghệ gì để
các bạn làm
theo
đấy tin nhắn tin nhắn là bắt đầu hơi khó
rồi
này trong thời gian thực
hợp phile Cái bên ngoài tương đối nâng
cao này tìm kiếm thì nh dễ rồi tin tin
nhắn khó nhá Còn theo thời gian thực nữa
đương nhiên là có thể dùng nhiều cái
công nghệ khác nhưng là ý ý tôi là chính
tôi thứ nhất là chưa làm nên tôi cứ đánh
giá nó khó trước đã nhưng mà bọ nhở nó
cũng một cái nâng cao r không phải cơ
bản có sẵn nữa đấy kết bạn theo dõi mấy
cái này cơ bản này toàn bộ mấy cái này
khá cơ bản này chỉ đăng Sợ xóa thôi Đấy
tìm kiếm cũng là cơ bản đấy thì Thực ra
riêng cái đống này đến cái ngưỡng này
này thông báo cũng khó thông thông báo
tin nhắn thực ra hai cái nó như nhau khó
riêng bảy cái gày đầu dòng này này bạn
làm xong rồi X bạn cải thiện dần về việc
quan trọng nhất cái bảng tin này này Đấy
đề xuất nó ra hợp lý bạn áp dụng thê bạn
nghiên cứu với toán để các thứ thứ để
làm xịn là việc là ừ Nói Chung Là làm
mọi thứ nó tương đối ổn đã cũng đủ làm
một cái pet Project rồi không cần nhất
thiết phải thêm mấy cái đương nhiên là
có respon ship thì nó là CS thôi Kiểu
chém thêm cái phim quốc xe là được còn
api ra mình tích hợp thêm api chatbot là
ngon quá rồi nĩa là phần bên thứ ba để
cho người ta tự nhắn tin vế nhau là cũng
hợp lý rồi không cần nhất thiết phải tự
làm tính năng tin nhắn với thông báo
bế tác quá học trên trường lẫn tự học
cảm thấy không hiệu quả đúng nếu mà
thường các bạn chủ yếu bây giờ các bạn
năm cuối cũng bắt đầu vẫn đang khá Mơ Hồ
về cái định hướng các thứ nên vẫn phải
làm thêm cái gì đó để các bạn cứ quan
trọng là phải bắt tay vào làm đã các bạn
mới hình dung được mình cần phải mình
thiếu cái gì mà mình cần phải làm bổ
sung thêm cái gì chứ bây giờ nếu mà cứ
kiểu đợi chờ một cái điều gì đó xảy ra
đợi chờ tự nhiên một hôm mình kiểu tỉnh
dậy rồi nghĩ à mình cần làm cái này à
Chắc chắn là không rồi đúng không ạ
Không phải đợi chờ một người nà nó nói
mình mình sẽ phải làm cái gì vì rõ ràng
là các bạn học đại học rồi khả năng tự
học các bạn và ý thức các bạn phải tương
đối cao chứ không còn là cái thời kiểu
kiểu tiểu học hay là trung học nữa Tại
sao gọi là trung học và tiểu học mà tự
nhiên lên kia biến hành đại học bởi vì
tôi cảm thấy Tiểu học Trung học Mình vẫn
có thể được phép cầm tay chỉ lối kiểu
kiểu các thầy cô phải g ý mọi thứ hết
sức có
như là vào đời của các bạn rồi các bạn
sẽ thấy môi trường xã hội Mọi thứ mọi
Nói thẳng luôn là có tệ nạn ở đấy cũng
có đấy để các bạn hình dung nhất ở ngoài
đời nó cũng sẽ giống hệ thế nó một xã
hội thu nhỏ trong đy nên là nên là bạn
phải làm quen dần việc đấy là về sau đi
làm cũng sẽ thế thôi Không ai cầm tay
chỉ lối không ai định hướng các bạn cả
các bạn phải
tự tìm tự làm tự tìm tự thử Mọi cái để
các bạn thấy cái nào phù hợp cái nào bạn
muốn làm các thơ thứ đúng không ạ Chứ
còn còn bây giờ khó lắm khó để mà khuyên
một cái gì cụ thể khi mà tôi hay là
chính bạn còn không hiểu được mình đúng
không
thứ đó làm khó không anh Anh nhớ là mấy
cái thằng ví điện tử bên thứ ba nó cố
làm api đơn giản để cho kiểu nhiều bên
tích hợp rồi nhưng mà anh không coi mấy
cái api đấy là mấy cái mấy cái gì đó nếu
mà em đang làm cho đồ án ấy đang làm cho
đồ án ấy thì
ờ anh không đánh giá cao mấy cái đấy bởi
vì nó không phải bài toán nghiệp vụ thì
quá ca siêu đấy còn nếu mà để em đang
làm cho kiểu công ty ha các thứ thứ thì
đương nhiên là công ty cần thì mình cứ
tích hợp mọi thứ vào thôi Nó có thư viện
hết cả rồi không khó lắm
học nó không siết chặt tất cả những cái
để cho các bạn làm quen dần gọi là trải
quen dần là ra ngoài đời Các bạn cũng sẽ
Thế ở trên ghế đại học các bạn không bị
lừa đảo thì ra ngoài đời Các bạn cũng bị
lừa đảo Thôi thả lừa đảo sớm lúc mình
chưa có tiền mình C bị lừa ít mình còn
đỡ cay mình còn làm lại được vân vân
đúng không ạ Nói chung là bước dần ra
khỏi cái bức tranh màu hồng đúng không ạ
tôi Thực ra tôi quen nhiều người vẫn còn
ở trong bước tranh mà hồng nhiều người
cũng từng trải rất nhiều đầy đủ đề loại
có người đến bây giờ vẫn còn bước tran
mà Hồng C nghĩa là họ 20 năm trong cuộc
đời nhưng mà họ vẫn toàn gặp người tốt
ấy thì tôi vẫn cố hy vọng họ là sẽ mãi
gặp được người tốt chứ họ mà ngã bây giờ
thì ngã hẳn không đứng dậy nổi vì họ
quen việc màu hồng quá rồi Kiểu như thế
còn tôi không khuyên mấy ông ở đây đó là
cố hướng Hồng đên Thế mấy ông phải có
nhìn thực tế hơn đấy thỉnh thả tôi sẽ
nói thẳng với cái thực tế như thế đó là
chẳng có kiểu tôi không thể vẽ cho mấy
ông mấy cái bức tranh m hồng ấy được tôi
sẽ nói thẳng sự thật như
mà m ông thấy không à quên chỗ này không
che tên rồi đấy đy Coi như là chưa nhìn
thấy gì nhá Đấy Ot này là không phải là
làm việc Ot đâu nhá Cho dù ông hiểu thế
cũng
ông xem quá không kịp thời ra nữa rồi 1
tiếng rưỡi rồi
à Mấy video này để xem à xem video
hiểu tại sao tí N xem lại không biết sao
ta nghe hay gì
tiếng ấ sợ mấy cũng không nghe được vì
mấy anh ấy chửi thì nó sẽ kiểu nghe
giọng hay Mọi thứ anh ấy hay nhưng là
tôi để mấy video này lâu lắm rồi Tôi
nghĩ là tôi sẽ để tạm cái vẫn còn để
video ở đây tôi sẽ nói hết mấy này trước
xong ngày hôm sau tôi sẽ cho coi như mấy
ông xem hết video rồi đi Thôi Xóa hết
một loạt đi TH là xong
OK nhệt ký ngày này năm xưa và sự thay
đổi không biết mấy ông như nào Nhưng mà
tôi hồi trước tôi đăng rất nhiều cái
video à rất nhiều cái link tating ở trên
Facebook không phải link tating nhưng mà
tôi gọi như là họ suy nghĩ mình thôi Tôi
không phải con người chia sẻ nhiều nhưng
mà đại khái thì à Ờ tôi dùng Facebook
cũng lâu rồi à từ 2010 à Thế Thành ra là
bây giờ ui 14 14 năm ạ nghe nhiều vậy
đấy nh đại khái thì kiểu nó con sẽ chia
sẻ rất nhiều nếu mà ngày này năm xưa thì
sẽ tận 10 năm trước gộp lại mà đúng
không th kiểu gì c chả có một ngày nà đó
Mình đăng cái gì đó ra tôi gần như ngày
nào cũng có cái thứ để xem lại tôi thấy
là kiểu cái sự thay đổi sự trưởng thành
mọi thứ của mình thì tôi coi cái thằng
Facebook coi như một cái quyền ký như
thế đế như là tôi đang bây giờ cũng để
chế độ bạn bè hay gì gì đó n mấy ông xem
chạ không lục lại được đâu nhưng mà tôi
coi đấy một cái khá là hay khá là hay m
có thể áp dụng cái đấy để cho làm mọi
cái khác kiểu dùng cái ứng dụng khác
cũng được không cần nhất đề Facebook
nhưng là coi như là một thứ gì đó lưu
lại để nó nhắc lại nó tạo động lực phần
nào đấy chỉ cần giả năm ngoái đến năm
nay thôi ông lại thấy kiểu Ui năm ngoái
mình đ như th này sao Bây giờ mình đã
thay đổi rồi còn Nếu giả sử mà vài năm
liền Ông thấy ông không thay đổi thì
đúng R cũng phải xem lại đúng không ạ
tôi lạc quan là tôi thấy là năm nào tôi
cũng thấy tôi thay đổi không phải về mỗi
ngoại hình nhá về rất nhiều cái suy nghĩ
hay mọi thứ khác thấy ổn hơn rất nhiều
Tiếp điều ước
Ờ tôi ghi lại cái này trong
rồi Thôi kệ đi không sao
Ờ tôi ghi lại cái tiêu đền điều ước này
lúc đấy các xếp cho cái kiểu như này
cuộc cuộc chơi như này đó là mọi người
ghi năm điều ước lại xong rồi ai trùng
được ba trong năm điều ước của các sếp
nghĩa là mình ghi năm điều ước các sếp
ghi năm điều ước đấy xong rồi mình mà
trùng được ba trong năm điều ước của
từng sếp nhá của từng sếp riêng nhá thì
sẽ được thưng cái thự gí đó tôi ghi được
đúng ba điều
ước tính là tôi không phải con người
không mơ mộng các thứ thứ hồi bé Tôi ước
nhiều lắm đến bây giờ tôi
vẫn tôi vẫn cảm thấy là tôi cũng cần
muốn một cái gì đó nhưng có vẻ Càng ngày
tôi càng cảm thấy là mình nên cố gắng
phấn đấu kiểu các thứ và bớt mơ mộng hơn
rồi thực tế hơn rồi tôi không Ngoài việc
thực tế là đương nhiên mình không tin về
việc là là mình ước mình sẽ được mà quan
trọng thực tế ở đây ám trẻ Tôi cảm thấy
à Nếu giả sử tôi có điều ước tôi không
phí điều ước và mấy cái đấy và tôi nghĩ
là tôi kiểu gì tôi cũng sẽ làm được nên
thành ra tôi không phí điều ước vào điều
đấy tôi cùng lắm à Lúc mà tôi ghi ba cái
đấy thì một cái là tôi ghi là sức khỏe
Này vở vì cảm thấy là bây giờ đúng là
mình đang hơi lười và đang hơi ý lại mọi
thứ các thứ các thứ mình hơi khó làm
điều đấy nên tôi sẽ ước th nhất sức khỏe
Thứ hai là tâm trạng luôn luôn ổn định
tốt thì phải tôi nhớ là tôi có ghi lại
trên insta thì phải tôi có chụp anh ở
cái đấy tôi xin phép tôi xem lại
định tích cực và cuối cùng là hạnh phúc
thực ra đương nhiên là mấy cái tích cực
và hạnh phúc đều là do mình quyết định
thôi Và thậm chí cả sức khỏ cũng thế thế
tôi cảm thấy là thậm chí là mình không
cần có điều ước không cần có mấy cái
điều ước đấy mình vẫn thể làm được mọi
thứ mình muốn ngay th hiện tại
rồi tươ nhiên là tôi đang nói tứ cách để
kiểu dạng cứ nhiều ông bảo nó sẽ kiểu bị
xáo rỗng hay gì gì đó nhưng tôi cảm thấy
là Tôi
đang tin mình làm được và tôi đang làm
được nó dần dần
rồi không biết mấy ông thấy nào chứ Rõ
ràng là là hồi bé tôi đã từng rơ mơ mộng
tôi từng ước rất nhiều
cái càng càng ngày tôi càng thấy là thực
ra tôi chẳng cần phải phí một cái điu
ước nào
không ạ bây giờ thỉnh thng tôi vẫn chơi
game mà tôi Ngày nào tôi chẳng xem game
Suốt vừa xem game vừa ăn cơm mà Ờ tính
ra tôi vẫn là thằng mọt game mọt
sách hơi nghiện thì Ờ nhưng mà nhưng mà
gọi nhỉ tôi không để nó làm ảnh hưởng
bất K khác bây giờ bận rộn đ nh không
thời gian chơi game tôi kiếm thứ khác để
vui
chơi rồi anh tính khi nào lập gia
đình khi nào có người để lập thì lập
thôi nói thế Nhưng mà thực ra mình phải
ổn định tư tưởng ổn định mọi thứ đã ít
nhất là về sự nghiệp thì tôi cảm thấy là
tương đối ổn tuy chưa phải ổn định bởi
vì rõ ràng mình hoàn toàn để thay đổi
nhưng mà tương đối nằm trong nằm trong
Tầm Kiểm Soát Rồi những cái thứ khác
đang hơi vẫn chưa kiểm sát được nên cần
phải cải thiện
sang depop không anh đá thẳng sang thì
chắc chắn là không vào đâu em sẽ phải đá
vòng qua biết về B backend tí đã để em
biết về back end bản bản chất là ngoài
ngoài ngôn ngữ ra thì thực ra là tôi
từng nói đó là tư duy của lập chính viên
fan thuần với fan à với lập trình viên
full stack và lập trình viên backend nó
khác nhau lắm bởi vì ở kiểu có rất nhiều
cái cần phải xử lý tối ưu hay là mọi thứ
Nói chung rất nhiều ấy thậm chí là tư
duy của lập trình viên Ngôn ngữ này Ngôn
ngữ kia nó còn có sự chứng lệch khác
nhau mà nên là một đp ốp theo tôi thấy
thậm chí là ở công ty tôi tôi khẳng định
chẳng mang tiếng có hai người làm dep
như tôi khẳng định hai người đấy cái
dạnh cái cái
cái gì à danh hiệu Chức vụ của bạn cái
gọi là tiêu đề dù từ như nào nhỉ chức vụ
Tên gọi
cái tiêu
tiếng Văn vọi
chưa Tôi hoàn toàn có thể nói cái đấy
tiếng Anh đơn giản title đúng không
nhưng tôi không Tôi không không muốn mất
gốc đến nỗi mình chỉ nhớ tiếng Anh mình
quên tiếng Việt à thể xem chức vụ
à danh hiệu danh hiệu tiêu
đi danh hiệu chắc không
nên
họ
ty tí Phả xóa
trò cũng hay nhưng mà ý tôi là cái cái
cái cứ cho cái m đi Ừ title dịch ra cái
m đi cái m đép ốp ấy đấy nó không đúng
với họ họ thực ra bản chất họ chỉ đang
chỉ đang làm là quản lý hệ thống quản
kiểu kiểu kiểu giám sát và quản lý hệ
thống thôi Kiểu Sếp tôi bảo à bảo là có
khi là nó system admin này nó phù hợp
hơn chứ chuẩn là họ đ ốp ấy
dep bản chất theo như tôi hiểu theo tôi
tìm hiểu với tôi cũng chưa làm mà nhưng
mà rõ ràng nó là đầu tiên thứ nhất là họ
phải biết đp đã đấy Đu Tôi hiểu rồi đúng
không Nghĩa họ biết đ cái đầu tiên phải
nói rõ về cái nguồn gốc của cái depop đã
Tại sao phải sinh ra cái cái kiểu danh
hiệu tiêu đề đấy cái gọi là vai trò hay
gì
trong công ty đi đấy Tại sao phải cần
cái đấy bởi vì rõ ràng đấy có một người
làm bên hệ thống có một người anh em
làm làm đép đấy thì rõ ràng là rõ ràng
là để mà nói chuyện nhau rất khó vì rõ
ràng là ông nào cũng chỉ biết vụ ông đấy
nhiệm vụ ông đấy làm ông chuyên cái này
thôi Nhưng mà nếu mà một người cầu nối
trung gian ông đấy ông đấy bây giờ làm
ông ông làm đé Ông cảm thấy là cần phải
cần phải làm kiểu dạng là ông làm đép
ông ấy cảm thấy cần làm tính năng ABC
này nhưng mà hệ thống bây giờ đang chưa
đủ đáp ứng thì ông ấy sẽ tự mình vào ông
ấy Build hay ông ấy deploy hay làm gì gì
đó để xây nó
lên chứ không ông kia nói là phải rõ
vàng s admin trước à Không theo tôi theo
tôi như tôi đang nói thì cái nguồn gốc
cái nguồn gốc theo tôi hiểu thì nó là
như kia cơ nguồn gốc là rõ ràng là ông
cần làm cái tính năng gì
đó thì ông thay vì ông sẽ đi nói với
thằng Seon admin là anh anh lên cho em
một cái này để em tích hợp vào không ông
ông không nên ông cảm thấy không muốn
phụ thuộc thế nữa mà đi ngồi giải thích
cho nó rất là lằng nhằng rất nhiều vấn
đề đề thì ông sẽ tự tay vào ông làm ông
nghiên cứu để ông tự phát triển lên một
cái hệ thống tự xây một cái hệ thống để
phục vụ cái tính năng đấy đấy thì rõ
ràng là tôi hiểu cái cái dep nó là như
thế có thể tôi đang chưa làm cái đấy th
tôi chưa biết được như tôi đang hiểu nó
depop theo hiểu kiểu dạng là nghe bài
toán xuôi nó sẽ là như thế nó nghe hợp
lý đúng không ạ Còn ở công ty tôi thì
mấy anh em kia chỉ làm phải quản lý hệ
thống và theo dõi chứ không không động
và đp luôn thành là cảm thấy à tên nó
vậy tôi không biết rõ ràng là như tôi
vừa nói thì nó là nguồn gốc thế thì nó
sinh ra cái cái vị trí đấy thì nó còn
hợp lý đúng không ạ Chứ ông bảo là B ad
min biết về hệ thống trước x nhảy và de
thì nó bị bài toán ngược mất rồi ông ông
hiểu không ạ Rõ ràng là mình nên nói
chung là cái vị trí nào nó ra đời cũng
là để giải quyết một cái gì đó trong
cuộc sống đúng không xử lý một cái gì đó
thì phải xử lý xử lý xuôi chứ nghĩa là
mình có một cái vấn đề này đúng không
Mình cần có vị trí này sinh ra để mà đảm
nhiệm cái cái cái đấy đấy thì theo tôi
là như thế nghĩa là anh em đé anh em
biết cần phải làm gì rồi cần cần phải
tích hợp thêm cái thằng ABC nào đó nhưng
bây giờ đi ngồi nói chuyện đi ngồi các
thứ nó rất là kiểu mất thời gian là rất
nhiều cái Nếu mà tự mình deploy tự mình
làm cái đấy tự Build nó lên được thì tốt
đấy để cho mình Độc Lập Mình không cần
phải bị phụ thuộc nữa đấy theo tôi là
như thế bởi vì cũng cái anh Minh mon men
anh đấy cũng chia sẻ cái đấy cho tôi
thôi anh đấy cũng làm cũng làm đp ốp các
thứ
thì ông đang từ dep fen ông đá thẳng
sang
dep thì tôi cảm thấy là là không ổn vì
rõ ràng là ông cần phải hiểu bài
toán bài toán kiểu làm đ các thứ thứ
trước
đã dep ốp mà không biết session trước
thì làm mệt hơn nhiều
À tôi tôi bảo tôi chưa học de nên tôi
không biết nói gì với ông Nhưng mà theo
tôi góp nhìn thì
ông kiến thức của depop thì đương nhiên
phải rất rộng và tôi thấy là chiên hướng
ở nhiều nơi thì đúng là depop thường hay
làm về bên hệ thống n nhiều hơn nên là
đúng có thể là basic thì họ cần mạnh
nhưng mà nhưng mà tôi cảm thấy là ví dụ
giống như là nó là bài toán thực tế bây
giờ thôi rất nhiều anh em đp hướng hướng
lên làm đp ốp mà thì rõ ràng là là cái
việc
là cái việc đấy hiển nhiên là đang xuôi
vì thấy rất nhiều người đang áp dụng Chứ
tôi thấy là hiếm anh em đang làm hệ
thống mà đi nhảy qua làm đép ốp
lắm không biết ông có gặp hay chưa Nhưng
mà tôi thì tôi chưa gặp tôi chỉ thấy anh
em làm hệ thống rồi anh em chỉ làm mỗi
thế thôi ấy còn anh em đ thì anh em đấy
muốn chuyển qua làm de các thứ thứ ngon
lành vì anh em hiểu bài toán nghiệp vụ
rồi anh em chỉ học thêm về mảng hệ thống
là thê th tự Build được các thứ thứ tự
làm được Kiểu cũng n nà dùng full stack
thôi nghĩa là mình không phụ thuộc vào
thằng làm fan nữa Thế giờ mình không phụ
thuộc về hệ thống nữa vì mình kiêm luôn
cả phần hệ thống rồi
background bên
ting background bên ting là
vẽ đúng
không Tôi nhớ là lập trình game cần phải
gii Toán thì phải nhớ
thể lập trình
game cần giỏi toán
không có người từng nói Tôi về cái vụ
lập trình viên cần phải giỏi
vẽ là ch đủ là đủ đâu em ạ nếu bên tinh
đang hiểu là vẽ thì không đủ
không CS thì vô vs code run debug rồi nó
chạy cho
ông chẳng hiểu đang trả lời câu nào bỏ
qua đ
Ờ chào sếp Chào
[âm nhạc]
bạn HT mlcs cầy đâu cho pro về ạ Em muốn
chuyên về về mỗi giao diện thì thực ra
là có một vài nơi học đấy ví dụ hồi
trước tôi gợi ý mấy ông code pen nà mấy
ông tham khảo lên đấy hoặc là mấy ông
thậm chí lên đấy tự tạo những cái sản
phẩm kiểu cắp các pen ấy để cho người
khác tham khảo cũng
hay Nhưng mà nếu mà em chỉ chuyên mỗi
giao diện thì anh cảm thấy nó hơi hơi bị
kiểu hẹp
quá nên làm thứ nhất là biết thêm về ra
scrip nữa này xong rồi để kiêm chuyên về
fen chứ giao diện thì không
đỉnh
phết Đúng là
kênh miếng ăn là miếng nhục tại sao hôm
đấy Mình ghi cái từ này
nhỉ Tôi hoàn toàn thể dựa vào một cái
tiêu đề này tôi ngồi chém gió cái gì rất
dài nhưng tôi không Nhớ Lý do tại sao
tôi ghi cái này
[âm nhạc]
rồi Thôi kệ đi Tôi tạm xóa
Ok bây giờ nếu mà không không nói thêm
gì cả thì tôi sẽ nói nốt cái cái này rồi
đành chấp nhận là hôm nay chỉ dừng lế
đây thôi à không tôi sẽ nói trước về hai
cái này đi vì nó liên quan
Đầu Năm của tôi
tiên năm ngoái tôi cảm thấy cứ cho Nếu
giả sử Nếu mà nói theo góc độ mê tín thì
năm ngoái tôi là một cái năm cái trò năm
hạn thì theo theo bói bảo thế thì tôi
cảm thấy là năm ngoái tôi gặp nhiều cái
thứ biế gọi là cũng biến cố thật nhưng
mà tôi thì theo quan điểm là luôn là do
mình thôi Do mình tư duy như thế nên mới
gặp những cái tình huống như thế
thì nhưng mà nhưng mà Bởi vì có kiêng có
lành nên tôi cũng có quan điểm đấy thành
ra tôi cũng cũng nên biết và cũng nên
hạn chế rất nhiều cái thứ đấy do năm
ngoái tôi chẳng đi đâu cả cho dù rõ ràng
tôi định dự định là tôi thậm chí cả nhả
việc hay làm gì đó
xóa hết đi mấy ông xem nhanh còn kịp
tôi cảm thấy là kiểu Mọi mình nên kiêng
làm rất nhiều thứ thứ cũng như là mình
Uầy ông không hiểu tôi đi tốc độ 20 cây
trên giờ đâu thế là đến bây giờ vẫn bị
quen thô tôi đi tốc độ chậm thấy chưa hố
trước là không đi chậm đế Thế đã từng có
thời cũng kiểu cũng trẻ trâu cũng phóng
nhanh như kiểu s m gọi vít hết cỡ có thể
rồi Ờ nhưng mà à thời Đệ cũng qua lâu
rồi nhưng mà nói chung là tôi hồi trước
là tôi đi xe V tốc vận tốc bình thường
40 các thứ các thứ 30 40 như cần đây đi
tốc độ 20 à Vì nói chung là làm mọi thứ
hết sức cần thận đấy còn đóng bảo hiểm
là đủ biết cẩn thận nhau rồi đấy nhưng
mà lúc mà sang năm
mới lúc mà sang năm mới này tôi đã nghĩ
là Ừ có thể thoát rồi C cho tạm thoát
rồi mình nên kiểu cũng bớt suy nghĩ đi
đề phòng vẫn đề phòng nhá Nhưng mà gọi
là mùng 1 mùng hai Đúng là cũng hơi hơi
đên đủi Thật cảm thấy hơi đen đủi thật
nhưng mà đương nhiên là tôi cảm thấy đấy
bây gi Tôi có câu hỏi đây đen đủi hai
thiếu cẩn thận
đấy bởi vì thực sự tôi cảm thấy là việc
đổ tại Số phận nó chẳng giải quyết được
cái vấn đề gì ở đây cả đ đổ tại số phận
thì ông lần sau lại tiếp tục thế à không
không như thế nên là tôi vẫn thường rất
hạn chế đồ tại số phận xem là mình rút
ra bài học gì từ đấy không để mình về
sau mình không bị dính phải đấy thì đầu
tiên thì mùng
1 mùng một của tôi thì tôi tôi bị dự ứng
Diêu mùng một tôi đi ăn với gia đình
ở Hà Nội thì đúng là nhà nhà bán bún rêu
rồi nhưng mà tôi đã cố Gọi bá nước trong
nhưng mà Đúng là tôi lúc đấy tôi hơi chủ
quan thật Bởi vì nếu mà chuẩn cho ông
nào không biết thì nếu mà chuẩn thì thì
sẽ cần có hai nồi nước một nồi nước
trăng một nồi nước dùng hôm đấy chắc
chắn là chỉ có một nồi nên thành ra Tuy
là bá tôi không bỏ Diêu vào nhưng mà một
nồi nước dùng thì kiểu gì chẳng dính
Diêu vào thành ra tôi vẫn dị ứng như
thường đấy
à và thì tôi chỉ biết Rút kinh nghiệm
lần sau Thấy quá nào một nồi thôi né ra
K là việc là
là tôi Thực ra tôi luôn mang thuốc dị
ứng theo người nhưng đúng hôm đấy không
mang thật đ chuẩn là phải luôn mang
nhưng mà hôm đấy thì đau bụng quá thì
cũng về nhà thì uống thuốc thôi không ấy
nổi mẩn khắp người mà may mà tôi dị ứng
cũng kiểu chị mức độ tương đối là kiểu
chỉ nổi mẩn V cả đau bụng chưa nỗi nằm
giật giật ở đấy Thế tính ra là tuy là
mình thiếu cẩn thận nhưng mà nó vẫn
không gây gì đó quá kinh
khủng đấy Tôi đang cố kiểu rất là lạc
quăn thậm chị tấu hài trong trong những
cái những lúc như này không sao vui mà
Đấy tiếp
ờ mùng 2 th ả không khá khẩm hôm mấy
mùng hai đi Văn Miếu à đi cùng đ đứa em
thì À hôm đấy Kiểu cũng rất là cẩn thận
chuẩn bị rất nhiều à mặc tận bốn áo áo
khoác nóng h mình nóng kinh khung kiểu
về cứ sợ lạnh cuối cùng Không Lạnh thế x
còn đi nhiều nữa không lạnh như thế Nóng
C bớt áo khoác ra xôi đưa nhờ thằng em
cầm hộ th thì lúc về
thì lục túi áo thì thầy mất cái chìa
khóa để ở trong túi áo
à lúc đấy th ra tôi chẳng trách gì thằng
em cả cho dù thằng em còn kiểu nói xin
lỗi các thứ thì tôi kệ thôi bảo thôi à
Không thực ra không phải lỗi em các thứ
thứ đó tai nạn các thứ kiểu không ai
muốn cả thì may mà tôi thấy là vẫn may
là kiểu tôi vẫn về để lấy kịp chìa khóa
sơ cua đấy Ít ra mình vẫn luôn có chuẩn
bị chìa khóa sơ cua đấy để mà lấy xe đấy
đương nhiên vẫn phải đi đánh lại một
loạt
chìa thì đế như rút được được gì bài học
ra từ đây để sao không bị như thế nhất
là Nếu giả sử mà nhờ ai cầm hộ như thế
thì thực ra mình cũng phải xác định rõ
luôn là khi mà mình nhờ người ta cầm hộ
cái áo thì đúng người ta chỉ cầm hộ mình
cái áo chứ không cầm hộ mình bất cứ cái
đồ đạc gì trong cái áo cả Nên là nếu mà
mất mát gì cho cái gì đó trong trong
tuổi ạo thì không thể trách được họ đúng
không ạ mình phải mình mình phải kiểu
một là nhắc họ trước hai là mình phải tự
bọc quả kiểu tự cầm
hay còn nếu không kỹ tính hơn nữa thì tự
mình cầm luôn cả cái áo không phải nhờ
đứ nào nữa đúng không ạ Chứ không thì
làm sao trách được người ta đúng không ạ
Người ta không để ý không biết gì
cả Thế thôi Đấy đấy là theo góc nhìn của
tôi mùng 1 mùng hai tôi ngay đầu năm nó
tôi cảm thấy là nó nó bị kiểu may Tôi
cảm thấy là cũng may là nó ở cuố ng ngày
không bị gián đoạn gì những cái chuyện
khác Nhưng mà tôi chia sẻ Các nhìn như
thế thôi Hy vọng là tôi luôn chia sẻ góp
nhìn theo kiểu tích cực lạc quan thế để
hy vọng truyền được các bạn cái tinh
thần cũng Lạc quan như tôi và cũng phải
cẩn thận nhá Không phải kiểu đổi tại
duyên số các thứ thứ
cũng hay
Ờ anh ơi cho xin ý chút ý tưởng để làm
app mobile Ừ đấy có hôm trước tôi bảo là
tôi có rất nhiều ý tưởng mấy ô cứ inbox
tôi tôi chia sẻ bớt cho xong rồi tôi bị
cứ để quên đấ có hình như có một hai ông
inbox qua fanpage rồi thì phải tí tôi
chả lời dần mấy ông nhắn tin nói chung
là nhắn tin qua Messenger tôi sẽ thường
hay kiểu nghĩ rằng là khi có thời gian
tôi mới trả lời à đ Đúng là tôi thường n
bị trôi thật nên là rất mong mấy ông nên
nhắn qua discord để tôi thường ha check
trên đấy hơn nếu nó liên quan đến công
việc nếu liên quan đến anh em kiểu tâm
sự thì đúng là nó khác thì tôi dễ trả
lời thì tôi trả lời nhanh được hoa dù đi
cà phê thì là tốt nhất
đấy Anh có ý định nhả việc không ạ Hay
làm luôn ở công ty hiện
tại hôm trước Hình như tôi có chia sẻ
rồi đó là kiểu tôi ra lúc mà ra trường
thì được nhảy vào công ty stup này rất
là ngon Nó vừa là may mắn vừa nhược điểm
may mắn là đấy thì mọi thứ đến thời điểm
hiện tại vẫn đang rất là ổn mình vẫn
hoàn toàn thể à phát triển bản thân ở ở
nơi này được à và có đãi ngộ m thứ cũng
rất là tốt nhưng mà nhược điểm đó là
tính ra mình hơi ít kinh nghiệm va chạm
các th thứ khi mà tính ra chỉ làm ở một
công ty nên là nhưng mà chắc là tôi sẽ
đi dậy và tôi sẽ va chạm ở những chỗ
khác
và khi mà cảm thấy là làm ở công ty này
chắc là phải cứ cho là ít nhất là cho
khi hết hợp đồng đi tới ký hợp đồng nm
năm à khi gi hết cho hết hợp đồng rồi
lúc đấy tôi tính dần sau cũng được Lúc
đấy có thể là là mình cảm thấy là mình
không phù hợp nơi này nữa có thể thế khi
mà tôi th ra tôi không hướng làm quản lý
nên là nơi này mà kiểu cứ bắt tôi lên
dần làm quản lý có khi tôi sẽ né thích
làm kiểu dep anh em à dep thôi quản lý
quản lý con người phức tạp lắm
Ừ hoặc là da nhỉ data B architect kểu
chắc là tôi có khi là tôi sẽ không quay
bkg thật vì ở đây cũng không còn người
kiểu Ờ còn có đúng một anh và anh chị
thân nhưng mà không phải kiểu cùng ban
ngành ấy à Chứ tôi tôi đi dậy tôi sẽ
hướng bên
FPT một Trân trời khá là tươi sáng hoặc
là bên bánh Khoa Aptech này thì có những
người thận kiểu dạng là tôi thấy cung
Trung định hướng với họ thì tôi nghĩ tôi
sẽ làm việc ở
bên khoa uptech có thể
lạnh suất Du hết để ta làm năm chỗ xong
rồi
bị tuần trước bị bạn lừa nhiều tiền Ui
ông này cũng bi đá thật
đấy thì đương nhiên là có rất nhiều thứ
kiểu dồn dập mình các thứ thứ thế nhưng
mà nhưng mà nó lại quay lại một cái câu
hỏi đôi khi là cũng phải hỏi lại đó là
tại sao đen đủi nó cứ ập đến như thế rất
nhiều người thường hay hỏi mình câu đấy
mà không hề Tìm thực sự câu trả lời đúng
không ạ en đủi ập đến mình Và thậm chí
nhiều đồng thời như thế Tại sao lại thế
do số phận à Không Tôi nghĩ là không
phải do số phận gì cả do tín hiệu Vũ Trụ
à do lực hấp dẫn của Vũ Trụ à Kiểu gì á
kiểu Nhiều người bảo do suy nghĩ tiêu
cực quá nên tiêu cực nó cuốn cuốn lấy
tôi nghĩ là chỉ đơn giản là do là thứ
nhất là đúng là do suy nghĩ thật là kiểu
Khi mà mình
à khi mình x nghĩ khi mà mình gặp nhiều
vấn đề mình bị quẫn chí thì chắc chắn
mình sẽ làm những cái thứ khác nó không
còn được minh mẫn sáng suốt thì mình sẽ
sẽ tự lao đầu vào những cái nó kiểu mình
tự gây tác động phần nào cũng ảnh hưởng
thôi vậy mình không còn minh mẫn tỉnh
táo làm quyết định mọi thứ nữa mà đúng
không ạ Nên là cái quan trọng nhất là
mình phải giữ lấy lại được cái bình tĩnh
nhất nhanh nhất có thể đã thì mình mới
có thể né được những cái tồi tệ khác sắp
đến chứ cái tồi tệ Thực ra nó vốn luôn
luôn có mế không phải Hình dung là như
thế Nói chung là những cạn Bẫy cuộc đời
đúng không nó luôn luôn có không phải là
kiểu Ui Bây giờ em mới thấy lần đầu
trong đời không nó luôn có Chẳng qua là
kiểu Mọi khi mình né được nó còn bây giờ
khi mà một khi mình bị giẫm vàoo rồi
mình kiểu mình bị nghĩ quẩn các thứ mình
lại lao đầu vào những cái bẫy khác thôi
la lao đầu những cái tiêu cực khác thôi
rõ ràng
là mình cần phải tỉnh táo lại để quyết
định cái bước đi tiếp theo của mình thì
nó mới ổn chứ không thì mình lại lao vào
sau lúc đấy mình lại đổi tại đời cho dù
rõ ràng Mọi khi nó vẫn nằm ở đấy đúng
không ạ Nó vẫn nằm ở đấy nó chẳng đi đâu
cả tự nhiên mình lao vào nó rồi mình lại
đi trách mình trách nó theo tôi là như
thế nếu mà ông suy nghĩ theo hư kiểu
hướng như thế thì có khi là mình né được
một cái gì đó đó thì mình có kh né được
còn nếu mà cứ suy nghĩ đổi tại đời thì
chắc là mình chẳng bao giờ né được đâu
mình cứ lao vào
thôi kẻ hủy diệt các các loại bẫy ơ ông
có khi ông lao vào thì thì cuộc đời cuộc
đời người khác sẽ cmm ơn ông vì ông dẫm
bẫy hộ người ta rồi có thể
thôi xin phép nếu không ai hỏi gì nữa
mấy ông đang câu hỏi đây này ồ đấy mấy
ông cũng đang câu hỏi các th thứ rồi th
xin phép hôm sau trả lời được không ạ
Còn tôi trả lời à Nhanh mấy câu hỏi đây
đã Ờ phải học những gì để đủ kiến thức
đi thực tập ạ mấy câu này tôi trả lời
nhiều quá rồi Ờ chắc lại phải nhờ mấy
ông hỏi ch GT tiếp nhá Chịu rồi
à chia sẻ về con l mới đi
anh tôi dùng đến thời hiểm Hiện tại thì
đúng là nó vẫn không đủ nó không hề tiện
cho lắm ch không phải cài đặt hay mọi
thứ và kết hợp việc chỉ đơn giản thôi
Đúng là dùng Macbook có cái hay Nó là
kiểu khi không cần dùng nữa chỉ gấp lại
coi như là thể xách đi được rồi nó tự
động Slip và kiểu lúc xong mình an tâm
việc nó Slip như thế chứ Bây giờ thì
đúng là gấp con LP Windows này thì đương
nhiên nó vẫn nó vẫn Slip thôi Nhưng mà
thực ra là nó vẫn bị nóng máy Tôi cảm
tôi nhớ hồi trước tôi từng đọc một cái
nó không tốt trong máy nếu mà ông để
trong cặp các thứ thứ nó bị kiểu bị hấp
nhiệt ấy đấy kh Ông vẫn phải thậm chí
ông phải S down hoặc là tôi thường tí
tôi sẽ phải mở chế độ hypernet lên nữa
đấy lắp Hồi trước tôi thích đu tôi định
mua con đo delo vbs à Nhưng mà tôi nhìn
thấy cổng của nó chỉ có mỗi hai cổng th
giống hệ m thì tôi nghỉ luôn giết Cái
con này của tôi có đầy đủ cổng này Thực
ra là tôi đầy đủ không đúng lắm Bởi vì
tôi cũng phải vừa mua cái Hub để mà thêm
một cái cổng nữa cổng mạng LAN để mà mai
tôi kết nối máy công ty à Chứ chứ con đo
XPS đấy nó chỉ hai cổng th tôi nghỉ luôn
Còn con đo này th p này của tôi Công
nhận thấy mọi thứ rất là ổn đúng R mọi
người khen nó có lý do cả nó có kiểu đấy
thì nó có riêng việc mở khóa khá tiện
đấy nó cũng có mở khóa vân tay giống hệt
con m Ừ cũng hay bàn phím gõ nghe nói là
thích hơn m Tôi cảm nhận được phần nào
cái điều đấy à còn gì nhỉ nóng nóng hơn
m có nóng hơn sờ vào nóng sau rồi nó có
quả Toàn nhiệt nhưng mà có vẻ vẫn nóng
hơn m Đúng rồi Win chạy khác
Ờ nhẹ cảm thấy khá là nhẹ kiểu cả cả cục
sác nữa Nói chung là bởi vì Vì trước tôi
dùng con Macbook e nên là tôi sẽ đánh
giá hai con nhẹ ngang bằng
nhau không biết chênh lệch được bao
nhiêu gam đâu vì mình đâu cảm nhận được
điều đấy
C đánh giá gì
thời điểm hiện tại tôi thấy là chạy vẫn
nhanh mượt chưa bị lag hay cái gì cả
không gặp vấn đề lỗi lủng gì
cả Tôi vừa nghỉ việc công t Cũ rồi không
biết nên chia buồn hay là nên chia vui
với ông
ạ Ok Cảm ơn ông à Nhờ không này cảm ơn
chúc mừng không Dạ tôi bị loạn ngôn rồi
máy mới mà lag bò đi vừa không Nghĩa là
trẻ đương nhiên là máy mới lag thì đúng
là Ừ có thể do Đẹ đen hật trước mắt là
tôi thấy là cũng có rất nhiều cái may
mắn gần đây xảy ra Ví dụ đấy tôi mua m
này à không phải phục vụ việc đi dậy đâu
tôi mua tôi đặt mua Nói chung là tôi cảm
thấy tôi cần mua ấy xô Đúng đúng phát đi
dậy này tôi cảm thấy là tôi đã tôi đã
làm hết mọi
thứ gọi là ví dụ là hôm trước vị đùng
phát bảo đi dậy đấy đúng không Nhưng mà
nhưng mà trước đấy tôi đã chuẩn bị cả về
mặt tin thần hay mọi thứ ấy đã ổn để may
ch để may chứ thí ra thì hôm trước bảo
thế Đúng Đúng kiểu có một tuần để chuẩn
bị việc đi Dậy luôn ấy nhiều người nghe
thấy bị gấp các thứ thứ đúng không Tôi
cảm thấy là tôi may tôi đ chuẩn bị hết
Mọi thứ trước rồi bây giờ Chắc là bây
giờ tắt stream xong rồi Tôi chỉ ngồi sửa
lại slide các thứ thứ để mai có thể tự
tin đi dậy được thôi chứ còn đâu thì về
mặt tinh thần hay là đấy về máy móc hay
mọi thứ khác may là tôi đã chuẩn bị
trước được trước lâu rồi
đấy tôi cảm thấy năm nay mọi thứ tôi có
vẻ đi khá đúng hướng từ đầu năm đến giờ
à nên là đấy tôi chia sẻ được cái năng
lượng tích cực này và tôi hy vọng là mấy
ông tìm được đến chúng ta tìm được đến
nhau cũng là một sự may mắn có thể tôi
sẽ may mắn của ông và cũng thể ông may
mắn thôi không biết được đừng rủ nhau đi
làm con lô là
được
Ok
đâ thà Nội lòng
à Hả Bây giờ ông ngồi kẻ Thôi muộn rồi
tôi tăn máy tôi ngồi chuẩn bị đáo án đã
chào mấy ông nhá để hẹn hôm khác nhá Hôm
sau khi phải ngồi tâm sự nốt và chia sẻ
Nốt này không biết bao giờ tôi mới quay
lại ngồi code cái dự án p kia tiếp đây
à thôi ông ng vẫn nhắn rồi ok Ngồi đọc
tôi vào công ty cũ vừa
nghỉ từ tháng 8 năm ngoái tôi làm kinh
doanh máy tính vì tôi chưa có kinh kinh
nghiệm nhưng có kiến thức tốt về phần
cứng máy tính nên tôi chỉ dám điu lương
và làm hưởng 85 ph chắc 85 ph này 85
ch 85 ph lương của 5 triệu à
sau 2 tháng thử việc đến khi làm tốt mà
chẳng được tăng lương 85 ph năng lượng
của năm Triều lại thấp quá đúng
lương thưng tích có 1 triệu th t 1 triệu
1 triệu là thường Tết 1 triệu thì tính
là nó vẫn cao Nếu mà lương ông chỉ 5
triệu Nếu tôi đang nĩ như
thế Ok tiếp không được đóng bảo hiểm xã
hội bảo hiểm y tế Ừ Nói chung là kiểu nó
bóp lột hết sức có thể đúng không Nói
chung là thời gian đầu mình mà cố kiếm
kinh nghiệm các thứ thứ nhưng là công
việc là công việc gì nhở làm kinh
kiểu kiểu dạng là làm phần cứng máy tính
đúng không kiểu it support môi trường
công ty to xí xếp hai các thử tử lôi
Ừ Nói chung
là đấy thì hôm trước tôi có chia sẻ đấy
Nó là kiểu khi mà đươ nhiên là mình Bây
giờ mình đang cố kiểu chọn chỗ nào để
làm thôi chứ thực ra nếu mà lý tưởng mà
khi mà mình được phép kén chọn ấy thì nó
phải sợi ba tiêu chí Đúng không Một là
đãi ngộ đãi ngộ tốt bao gồm lương xong
rồi mấy cái kiểu đi kèm kia đúng không
Hai là môi trường làm việc bao gồm cả
xếp với những cái đấy là nó sẽ không
được thay đổi được được đúng không ạ Và
Ba là cái công việc đấy cái cơ hội phát
triển của nó mọi thứ nó như th nào ổn
hay
không thì bạn không đáp ứng được cả ba
cái đấy à Bạn đáp ứng được một trong ba
cái đấy là bạn vẫn có thể phát triển
được kinh nghiệm thì ok bạn vẫn thể ở
lại còn nếu mà cả ba cái đều không ổn
thôi đi thôi không còn gì lưu luyến
Ờ bạn đấy không biết bạn đấy có đang
ngồi gõ tiếp hay không nhưng tôi phải
tặng tắt đ không sẽ kéo dài không biết
đến bao giờ ờ
Ok Nói chung là chúc mừng bạn và hi và
tôi nghĩ là với cái tôi đọc vừa rồi cũng
chưa biết gì về bạn Nhưng mà đọc qua Thế
có vẻ là tôi nghĩ là bạn vẫn sẽ tìm được
kiểu công việc mới phù hợp với mình hơn
thôi vì ít nhất là tư tưởng thoải mái
như thế n ồn rồi vì nhiều người nghỉ
xong người ta C Lưu Luyến lắm người ta
còn muốn quay lại cơ ngay là việc C chia
tay xong quay lại vậy Nói chung là kiểu
mình phải xác định rõ là mình rút ra
được gì mọi thứ từ nó và nó cũng chỉ nên
đến một cái mức độ nào đó thôi là mình
cũng phải biết buông rồi đúng không
Nghiêm Túc Như hôm trước anh nói ý à Thì
cái khóa học nghiêm túc đấy là phải lâu
lắm cơ Bởi vì tôi sẽ định đi dậy ở nơi
Nói chung là Lúc đầu định dạy ft Nói
chung là còn phải đi Thứ nhất là tôi sẽ
tham gia một vài khóa học ổn này thôi
tôi đi dậy ở Tôi đi dậy một thời gian ổn
đã và có má các thứ thứ xịn xịn đã giảng
viên evt hay giảng viên B khoa gì không
biết đây xong rồi tôi sẽ liên kết với
bên spum để mà đăng các khóa học lên đấy
là kiểu khóa học online lên nền tảng của
họ và họ sẽ nhờ họ để mà làm Slide hay
mọi thứ rất là rất là bài bản Chuẩn chỉ
từng buổi từng buổi và lúc đấy nó sẽ bao
gồm việc là cam kết đầu ra của bên đấy
luôn là bên đấy sẽ hỗ trợ kết nối à kiểu
các doanh nghiệp hộ cho các sinh viên để
mà kiểu sinh viên học mấy cái đấy xong
vẫn có thể hỗ trợ việc làm các thứ ý
thậm chí là cấp cả chứng chỉ mà nói
chung là mọi thứ chuẩn chỉ như thế thì
mình phải có những bước gạch đầu tiên ổn
đã thì bây giờ tôi đang phải cải thiện
rất nhiều cái để có nên móng đã
em muốn học cấu trúc dữ liệu và giải
thuật nhưng phải thành thạo Một ngôn ngữ
thì làm nào để học ngôn ngữ à cần gì th
c ch cần ngôn ngữ gì đâu nhỉ ngôn ngữ ở
đây em học SQL đi em ạ Đúng fq là ngôn
ngữ mà language mà đấy Em chỉ cần SQL th
nhá Thôi kết thúc nhá Còn ông kia SQL
nhá Anh có khóa học playlist rồi đấy
khóa học tâm huyết của anh đấy Bye bye
Chào mọi người ạ
h